I'm Jennifer Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who are there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello! Ho you ready for some Christmas wishes? Boy am I!
我是珍妮弗·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为您制作终极的《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有当时在场的两个人才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室辣妈。你好！嗨，你准备好迎接一些圣诞愿望了吗？天哪，我太准备好了！
This is season 8 episode 10. It was written by Mindy Kaling. This was her third Christmas episode, Angela. I did not realize she was the go-to Christmas writer until we started this rewatch. Apparently so. She also wrote Diwali. She's like our, I guess, if it's a holiday, give it to Mindy. Yeah. This episode was also directed by Ed Helms. This was his directorial debut. So I would do this thing when we had a cast member who directed for the first time. I would get everyone to sign the script and give it to them as a gift.
这是第八季第10集。它由敏迪·卡林编剧。这是她的第三部圣诞剧集，安吉拉。直到我们开始这次重温，我才意识到她是御用圣诞编剧。显然是的。她还写过《排灯节》。她就像我们的，我想，如果是假期，就交给敏迪吧。是的。这一集也是由埃德·赫尔姆斯执导的。这是他的导演处女作。所以每当有演员第一次当导演时，我都会做这件事。我会让每个人都在剧本上签名，并把它作为礼物送给他们。
Aw, yeah, and I gave it to Ed and he was like, and I love this! Well I was not in this episode. I was at home with my new baby, so I did not get to participate in any of the fun stuff that happened and oh my gosh, this episode has a lot. Here's your summary. Determined to make this the best office Christmas party ever, Andy promises to make each employees holiday wish come true. Meanwhile, Dwight and Jim are pranking one another and someone has complained.
哦，是的，我把它送给了埃德，他当时的感觉是，我太喜欢这个了！好吧，我没有参演这一集。我在家里带着我的新宝宝，所以我没有参与任何发生的有趣的事情，天哪，这一集有很多内容。这是你的摘要。安吉拉决心让这次办公室圣诞派对成为史上最棒的一次，他承诺让每个员工的圣诞愿望成真。与此同时，德怀特和吉姆在互相恶作剧，有人抱怨了。
Someone in their desk clump. Yes. And Andy gives them an ultimatum. Yes, he does. He says the two of you need to stop pranking each other or I'm gonna give your Christmas bonuses to the other person. Mm-hmm.
他们办公桌群里的人。是的。然后安吉拉给他们下了最后通牒。是的，他确实这么做了。他说你们俩需要停止互相对方恶作剧，否则我要把你们的圣诞奖金给对方。嗯。
Meanwhile, Robert California tries to forget his divorce woes by doing shots with Aaron, who gets very, very drunk at this party. Maybe more drunk than Meredith? Maybe, debatable. It's saying a lot if you get more drunk than Meredith at a holiday party. I mean, Meredith was on the floor by the end of the night, so she might have still kept her record as the most drunk at the party.
与此同时，罗伯特·加利福尼亚试图通过和艾琳一起喝烈酒来忘记他离婚的烦恼，艾琳在这次派对上喝得非常非常醉。也许比梅雷迪思还醉？也许吧，这有待商榷。如果你在节日派对上喝得比梅雷迪思还醉，那可真说明问题了。我的意思是，派对结束时梅雷迪思都躺在地上了，所以她可能还是保持着派对上喝得最醉的纪录。
That's true. Good point. Well, listen everyone, we are going to kick off this episode of Office Ladies with an interview with the one and only Amina Kaplan. You know, she appeared as Val in 14 episodes of the office, including Christmas wishes. Amina attended Tisch School of the Arts in New York, and she has won theater awards for choreography, and she can play the drums.
那是真的。说得好。好吧，听着各位，我们将以对独一无二的阿米娜·卡普兰的采访来拉开《办公室辣妈》这一集的序幕。你知道的，她在《办公室》的 14 集里饰演瓦尔，包括《圣诞愿望》。阿米娜就读于纽约的蒂施艺术学院，她曾因编舞获得过戏剧奖，而且她还会打鼓。
Can she play the drums? She's like a professional drummer and now a director. We can't wait for you to hear this interview. We love her. Yes. So without further ado, here you go. I mean, oh, hi!
她会打鼓吗？她就像一个专业鼓手，现在还是一位导演。我们迫不及待地想让你听到这次采访。我们爱她。是的。那么废话不多说，给你。阿米娜，哦，嗨！
Hello! Hey, everybody, what's up? How you all doing? Oh, good! So good to see you. It's good to see you too. It's been a while. It's been a hot minute in fact. It's been long. Sure has. And we're zoom in with you today. You're in New Orleans. I am. This is my first time in New Orleans. It's awesome down here. It's a special place to me. I was born Louisiana and then I was born in Lafayette and I did two movies in New Orleans and my family would come and visit and so I'm going to email you a few spots that you've got to check out. I would love that because I have the rest of my afternoon, like after four o'clock, I'm going to be free. So that's all I'm going to do is just go around
你好！嘿，大家好，怎么啦？你们最近怎么样？哦，很好！很高兴见到你。我也很高兴见到你。好久不见了。事实上已经有一会儿了。好久没见了。确实是。我们今天通过 Zoom 和你连线。你在新奥尔良。是的。这是我第一次来新奥尔良。这里太棒了。对我和说这是一个特殊的地方。我出生在路易斯安那州，然后在拉斐特出生，我在新奥尔良拍了两部电影，我的家人会来看我，所以我打算发邮件给你一些你必须去看看的地方。我很乐意，因为我的整个下午，比如下午四点之后，我都会有空。所以我要做的就是四处走走
to spots in New Orleans. So because we're working hard here. So we have like this full schedule, although I took this hour out to hang out with you guys. Thank you. Oh, we love that. It's my pleasure. Thank you so much. Well, we'll jump right in there. Yeah.
去新奥尔良的各个地方。因为我们在这里努力工作。所以我们有这样一个完整的日程安排，虽然我抽出这一个小时来和你们一起玩。谢谢。哦，我们喜欢这样。这是我的荣幸。非常感谢。好吧，我们马上切入正题。是的。
We're going to ask you the question that we ask every guest to kick things off, which is, how did you get your job on the office? Uh-huh. Awesome casting director, Alison Jones, cast me. I was literally just an actor in LA just doing my thing and it literally just came through as a regular audition. There it was, just like boom,
我们要问你一个我们问过每个嘉宾来拉开序幕的问题，那就是，你是怎么得到《办公室》这份工作的？嗯。出色的选角导演艾莉森·琼斯选中了我。我当时在洛杉矶真的只是一个普通的演员，做着我自己的事，它真的就像一次常规试镜一样来了。就这样，就像轰的一声，
there's a character on a TV show, you're right for it, you're gonna go in for that job and it turned out to be serendipitous and special in that I was acquainted with Craig Robinson before I went into my audition. I did not know he was going to be at the callback. I didn't actually see him. He saw me.
电视节目里有一个角色，你很适合，你要去参加那个面试，结果发现这是命中注定且特别的，因为在我去面试之前我就认识克雷格·罗宾逊。我不知道他会出现在回调面试中。我其实没看到他。他看到我了。
If you ask Craig, Craig would be like, you don't even know how much I got you on that show. So I'm like, all right, Craig, whatever. I always do you. So I give him the credit. I think Craig really was like, oh snap, that's a mean I know a mean. And we're both musicians.
如果你问克雷格，克雷格会说，你甚至不知道我在那个节目上多么挺你。所以我说，好吧，克雷格，随便你。我一直都很支持你。所以我把功劳归于他。我觉得克雷格当时真的是，哦天哪，那是阿米娜，我认识阿米娜。我们都是音乐家。
And so we kind of knew each other from the music scene. Yeah, you played drums, right? That's right, yeah. I'm a drummer, I honestly feel like that's kind of the only real thing that I am. I'm a hack with everything else, because looking back at it at this age, I'm like, yeah, drumming, that's the thing that I did
所以我们从音乐圈就互相认识了。是的，你打鼓对吧？对的，是的。我是个鼓手，我老实觉得这差不多是我唯一真正擅长的东西。我对其他所有事情都是半路出家，因为到了这个年龄回想起来，我会觉得，对啊，打鼓，那是我
when I was nine years old. I just was beating on stuff. I was like hitting things and making rhythms and making beats on desktops and stuff. Then when I was 12, a guy taught me how to play both the blue sky by YouTube on the drum set and I was like, okay, and I was terrible for years and years and years, because I had no training in my family.
九岁时做的事。我只是在敲打东西。我敲打东西，在桌面上敲出节奏和节拍之类的。然后当我 12 岁时，有个家伙教我在架子鼓上弹奏 YouTube 的《蓝天》，然后我说，好吧，我连续好几年都烂透了，因为我的家庭没有任何训练。
It was like, what do you think you're doing playing drums? And I was like, I'm doing this. But yeah, I'm a drummer and have been, this will be a long time. Like this year will be 40 years of playing, once I, like'm doing this. But yeah, I'm a drummer and have been, this will be a long time. Like this year will be 40 years of playing, once I, like later this year. And so yeah, it is the only thing that I really am. Yeah, and Craig's a musician.
当时的感觉是，你以为你在打鼓干什么呢？然后我说，我在做这个。但是是的，我是一个鼓手，并且一直是，这将是很长的一段时间。就像今年将是演奏的第 40 年，一旦我，就像我在做这个。但是是的，我是一个鼓手，并且一直是，这将是很长的一段时间。就像今年将是演奏的第 40 年，一旦我，就像今年晚些时候。所以是的，这是我唯一真正是的身份。是的，克雷格是个音乐家。
And we were in a band full of actors. So if anybody got a gig, nobody was worried. It was like, okay, whatever, I booked the thing, okay, whatever. And Craig was friends with the guys in the band. And they used to hang out. And being the girl in the band, I never really hung out with them, but we were around the same scenes. Right, right. Yeah. Oh, and my heart right now, if there ever is an office reunion, Val's got to play the drums.
我们曾在一个全由演员组成的乐队里。所以如果有人接了演出，没有人会担心。感觉就是，好吧，管他呢，我接了那个演出，好吧，管他呢。而且克雷格和乐队里的伙计们是朋友。他们经常一起出去玩。作为乐队里唯一的女孩，我从来没有真正和他们一起玩过，但我们在同一个圈子里。对，对。是的。哦，我现在的内心啊，如果《办公室》真的有重聚的话，瓦尔一定要打鼓。
Val's got a boot Kevin out of the band. I know, was it killing you when you had to sit and listen to them play and you're like, I could be the drummer in Kevin in the, Kevin in the Zitz. I'm not even gonna mince words. The answer is yes. I was standing there and I was like, you gotta be kidding me right now. They are playing drums like two feet in front of me. That's crazy.
瓦尔要把凯文赶出乐队。我知道，当不得不坐在那里听他们演奏，然后心想我本来可以当凯文在那个，凯文在 Zits 乐队里的鼓手时，你有没有痛不欲生？我甚至不会拐弯抹角。答案是肯定的。我当时站在那里心想，你们现在一定在逗我。他们就在我前面两英尺的地方打鼓。这太疯狂了。
Like why am I standing here? And why is Bal not on the drums? Why is she not the secret killer? And you know it's just one of those things. I was the new kid. It was Brian's moment and it was awesome. We had the drummers at the wrong band. It was just heaven. That day it was that episode It was just heaven for me and totally frustrating that I didn't speak up about being a drummer. I kind of kept those worlds separate Because when I got to LA it was weird like coming from New York where you could be a triple threat as they called it or whatever Right come into LA. It was like, well, what are you? Are you an actor? Are you a drummer? Are you a dancer? Like coming from New York where you could be a triple threat as they called it or whatever. Right.
就像我为什么站在这里？为什么瓦尔不在打鼓？为什么她不是那个秘密杀手？你知道这只是其中之一。我是新来的。那是布莱恩的高光时刻，太棒了。我们把鼓手放错了乐队。简直就是天堂。那天那一集对我来说简直就是天堂，而且完全沮丧的是我没有大声说出自己是个鼓手。我有点把这两个世界分开，因为当我来到洛杉矶时，这很奇怪，就像从纽约来一样，在那里你可以像他们所说的那样成为三栖明星，或者随便什么，对吧。来到洛杉矶。感觉就像，好吧，你是什么？你是个演员吗？你是个鼓手吗？你是个舞者吗？就像从纽约来一样，在那里你可以所以，像他们所说的那样成为三栖明星，或者随便什么。对吧。
Coming to LA, it was like, well, what are you? Are you an actor? Are you a drummer? Are you a dancer? So I never told anybody that I did the other thing. I did the other thing to keep from waiting tables, you know. Yeah. And so, but I never told anybody that I played drums.
来到洛杉矶，感觉就像，好吧，你是什么？你是个演员吗？你是个鼓手吗？你是个舞者吗？所以我从未告诉任何人我做过另一件事。我做另一件事是为了避免去端盘子，你知道的。是的。所以，但我从来没有告诉任何人我会打鼓。
If you knew I was a drummer, you knew. So I didn't come into my acting auditions like, I'm a drummer You know, trying to book a job is like a young mom or something. So I didn't come waving my rock and roll flag. So it is so interesting because during that time, we were all auditioning around the same time back then. And it really was kind of like staying your lane, you know, you're an actor. But I feel like now people really share, I think social media has helped that that you can share all the things you do and people learn. Oh, you're this, this and this and that's great.
如果你知道我是个鼓手，那你就是知道了。所以我去试镜时不会表现得像，我是一个鼓手，你知道的，试图作为一个年轻妈妈什么的去争取一份工作。所以我没有挥舞着我的摇滚旗帜。所以这太有趣了，因为在那段时期，我们所有人当时都在差不多同一时间试镜。而且这真的有点像是各司其职，你知道的，你是个演员。但我觉得现在人们真的很乐意分享，我认为社交媒体对此有所帮助，你可以分享你所做的一切，人们会了解。哦，你是这个、那个还有这个，这太棒了。
Yeah. You know what? I'm going to say we did that. We pioneered that because I was doing it before social media. I'm from the 90s. We're everybody on this podcast. We're from the 90s. Let's get our credit, Jen.
是啊。你知道吗？我要说我们做到了。我们是这方面的先驱，因为我在社交媒体出现之前就在这样做了。我来自 90 年代。我们这个播客上的所有人。我们都来自 90 年代。让我们获得应有的赞誉吧，珍。
X. Let's get our credit because I got it. We were doing it in the cut. Like I'm saying, I just didn't tell anybody. Right, right. And if people did find out actually got made fun of one time, because somebody was like, oh, really? You think you're all like, oh, so you're an actor
X 一代。让我们获得应有的赞誉吧，因为我得到了。我们一直在幕后默默努力。就像我说的，我只是没告诉任何人。对，对。而且如果人们真的发现了，我其实还被取笑过一次，因为有人说，哦，真的吗？你觉得你挺了不起的，哦，所以你是个演员
and you're a musician? You know, nobody was encouraging this little chocolate drop to get into this business. So I took precautions. I didn't brag. I wasn't around telling people that I played with Rihanna or that I had played with Macy Gray. Or I just was like, in there sitting down,
还是个音乐家？你知道的，没有人鼓励这个小黑人女孩进入这个行业。所以我采取了预防措施。我没有吹嘘。我没有到处告诉别人我和蕾哈娜一起演出过，或者我和梅西·格雷一起演出过。我只是像，坐在那里，
just trying to survive. I was just trying to do a good job, you know? But I do think that now we know that you have to be a multi-hyphenate. We're artists, which means that we are absorbing things from everywhere. We're taking inspiration from means that we are absorbing things from everywhere. We're taking inspiration from everything, and we are all multifaceted. I'm glad it's being celebrated now.
努力生存。我只是想做好工作，你知道的？但我确实认为，现在我们知道你必须具备多种斜杠身份。我们是艺术家，这意味着我们在从各个地方吸收事物。我们在汲取灵感，意味着我们在从各个地方吸收事物。我们从一切事物中汲取灵感，我们都是多面手。我很高兴现在这一点受到了赞美。
I'm glad. Well, you brought something up that reminds me of what my best acting coach ever told me about making it in Hollywood or in an artistic career. And what that is is that you need to cultivate a consistent body of work, where every time you show up to do a job, you are consistent, you are good, you do your thing. And that is what is going to propel you forward.
我很庆幸。好吧，你提到了一件事，让我想起了我最好的表演教练曾经对我说过的话，关于如何在好莱坞或艺术生涯中取得成功。那就是你需要培养一贯的代表作，每一次你出现在工作中，你都是稳定发挥，你都很优秀，你做好你该做的事。这就是推动你前进的动力。
It's not meeting someone at a party or schmoozing someone in a meeting. Your work is what speaks for you. It sounds like that's what you're talking about every time in this world, it was just like people showing up, creating a consistent body of work, and everybody just being their best artist self. We had to be, you know, Jenna, it was like,
不是在派对上遇到某人或在会议上巴结某人。你的作品才是为你说话的东西。听起来这就是你所说的，在这个世界上的每一次，都只是人们出现，创造一贯的作品，每个人都展现出自己最好的艺术家自我。我们必须这样，你知道的，珍娜，这就好像是，
it was one of those things like I was saying, like people weren't encouraging me to get into the arts. The arts called me, and I recognize that now from my forties that I literally was just doing it. I was one of those kids. So that's what we did. I knew that I would have to make art. I knew it. You know, and when I met you guys when we were doing the office, I was already in film school. I had already made this decision that I was going to go make less money directing live entertainment because that's where my heart was was in live entertainment and just really viscerally connecting to the audiences, you know. And I was trained
就像我刚才说的，那是一种感觉，人们并没有鼓励我进入艺术界。艺术召唤了我，现在到了四十岁我才意识到这一点，我当时真的只是在做这件事。我就是那种孩子。所以这就是我们所做的。我知道我必须创作艺术。我心里清楚。你知道的，当我在我们拍《办公室》时遇到你们时，我已经读电影学校了。我已经做出了决定，我要去导演现场娱乐节目赚更少的钱，因为我的心就在现场娱乐节目中，并且真正发自内心地与观众建立联系，你知道的。而且我从小就受过训练
from a young age that you make art, you make art, you make art. And so that was what we did. And so those were the people that I gravitated to. And so those like-minded people, yeah, we connected. And I think there were a lot of those people on the office. The majority of our cast had been just for years trying to find their artistic avenue. For me, I was doing improv for like eight years. I was on stage every chance I got. Everyone was doing things like that. There weren't any overnight successes. We had some young writers, but they had been doing their thing in college.
你要创作艺术，创作艺术，创作艺术。所以这就是我们所做的。这也是我所吸引的人。所以那些志同道合的人，是的，我们联系在了一起。而且我认为《办公室》里有许多这样的人。我们的大多数演员多年来一直在努力寻找他们的艺术途径。对我来说，我一直在做八年即兴表演。我抓住每一个机会上台。每个人都在做类似的事情。没有什么一夜成名。我们有一些年轻的作家，但他们从大学起就在做自己的事情。
But when I look at our cast, we had all been there for years, just doing our art and waiting for our moment and being ready. That's right. I'm in the same bucket. Like people asked me, you know, what did you think of the office or whatever?
但当我看着我们的演员阵容时，我们都在那里待了好几年，只是在做我们的艺术，等待我们的时刻，并做好准备。没错。我和你是同一类人。就像人们问我，你知道的，你觉得《办公室》怎么样？
That's one of the main things that I say is that Alson Jones, that casting director, she was looking in the cut for us. All those performers like us who were the lifers, who maybe we didn't look a certain way, whatever. Like, whatever those boxes are, we didn't check them. We checked the box of, this is what I must do because this is who I am.
这是我主要会说的事情之一，艾莉森·琼斯，那个选角导演，她就是在幕后寻找我们。所有像我们这样把一生奉献给表演的演员，也许我们长得不是某种样子，管他呢。就像，无论那些条框是什么，我们都没有符合。我们符合的条框是，这就是我必须做的，因为这就是我。
And I'm gonna do it. And I'm gonna get a part because I have to, because I am a working actor. You know, we're just gonna be in that category. Maybe we will get Uber famous. Maybe we won't, but I'm gonna tell you right now you're gonna know because we're in the cast. And Allison was looking for us. And it took us years because again, we weren't doing it the same way.
我要这么做。我要得到一个角色，因为我必须这么做，因为我是一个职业演员。你知道的，我们就会属于那一类。也许我们会超级有名。也许不会，但我现在就要告诉你，你会知道的，因为我们在演员阵容中。艾莉森一直在寻找我们。这花了好几年时间，因为同样地，我们不是用同样的方式在做这件事。
We weren't gonna be the splash in the pan. And I'm forever grateful to that. And I walked in there and I felt that energy. I could feel you guys all like, oh okay no granted you all were seven years ahead of me in terms of down the line, you know, but I was like these people are real up in here. These are the actors right here. Alson, she's done this. She's curated this cast and I'm grateful. I'm grateful to that because it took me a long time. Like I said, I'm alternative, you know, I look for a certain way that maybe betrays the way I speak
我们不会只是昙花一现。对此我永远心存感激。我走进去，感受到了那种能量。我能感觉到你们所有人都在，哦，好吧，当然，你们在资历上比我早了七年，你知道的，但我觉得这些人在这里是认真的。这些才是真正的演员。艾莉森，她做到了。她精心挑选了这个演员阵容，我很感激。我很感激这一点，因为这花了我很长时间。就像我说的，我是另类的，你知道的，我的外表可能与我说话的方式
in my background or whatever it is. And it took Hollywood and the world, frankly, a long time to try figure out what I am, who I am, and where I'm coming from. But Alson was like, I got you. She's so great. Yeah, I got you. She's so great. Yeah, I got you. When you auditioned, did you know that this was going to be a multi-episode arc? It did you know that it was going to be a love story? So I knew about the potential, but they tested me out. Like they screen-tested me in my first couple of episodes, but I had an inkling that it
以及我的背景不符，或者无论是什么。坦白说，好莱坞和全世界花了很长时间才弄清楚我是什么人，我是谁，我来自哪里。但艾莉森觉得，我懂你。她太棒了。是的，我懂你。她太棒了。是的，我懂你。当你去试镜时，你知道这是一个多集的故事线吗？你知道这将是一个爱情故事吗？我知道有这种潜力，但他们测试了我。就像他们在我的前几集里对我进行了银幕测试，但我有一种预感，如果我表现得好，
would go well if I did a good job, but I needed to do a good job in order for it to happen. And I was happy to be in that spot because I felt so strongly that the writers were working with me, that they wanted me to succeed, that the Paul and everybody wanted me to succeed.
事情会进展顺利，但我必须表现好才能让它发生。我很高兴能处于那个位置，因为我强烈地感觉到编剧们在和我合作，他们希望我成功，保罗和每个人都希望我成功。
So it just felt in the pocket. Like I felt that support, I felt support from John Przinski. When I first got there, I just felt people going, come on in Amina, you know, we want you to succeed. And so it was great. Well, you know, we're just watching Christmas wishes. And that's when your character comes up to the bullpen, right? The popsicles comes and joins the popsicles.
所以感觉很契合。就像我感受到了那种支持，我感受到了来自约翰·卡拉辛斯基的支持。我刚到那儿时，我就能感觉到大家都在说，进来吧，阿米娜，你知道的，我们希望你成功。所以这太棒了。好吧，你知道，我们正在看《圣诞愿望》。那就是你的角色走到办公区的时候，对吧？冰棒来了，加入了冰棒们的行列。
And I remember, that was really the first time we all got to work with you. I know you had all these scenes in the warehouse, but now you're up in the bullpen, you're up in a Dundermifflin office. You looked so fantastic. Thank you. You looked so beautiful.
我记得，那真的是我们所有第一次有机会跟你合作。我知道你在仓库里有很多戏份，但现在你来到了办公区，来到了邓德米夫林的办公室。你看起来太棒了。谢谢。你看上去太美了。
You really do, Amina. And now, you know, I was disappointed that I did not get to be there in person for your big bullpen scenes, but I wasn't in Christmas wishes. I missed a lot of your episodes because I was new mom. That's right. You were definitely that was what was going on at that time. Yeah. You were a new mom. Yeah. It's all such a whirlwind for me. Like I think maybe Jenna, you and I really started working together in the final season nine. Nine. Yeah. Right. Right. Yeah. Well Jenna, we missed having you on set. And I missed like what was Pam's outfit for this year? Yeah. That's that's a whole other thing. But I mean,
你真的很好，阿米娜。现在，你知道，我很失望没能亲自去现场看你的大办公区戏份，但我没有参演《圣诞愿望》。我错过了你的很多集，因为我是个新手妈妈。没错。你当时确实在忙那个。是的。你是个新手妈妈。是的。对这一切我感到眼花缭乱。就像我想珍娜可能你和我真的开始合作是在最后一季第九季。第九季。对。对。对。好吧，珍娜，我们真怀念你在片场。我也怀念潘今年的衣服是什么样的？对。那是另一码事。但我的意思是，
I remember just how excited we were to have you up there. The cast, you know, we had seen your storyline because we would watch the episode. Yeah. And now we got to be with you. And do you have any memories of what it was like when you walked into the bullpen? Yes. It's terrifying. It was nerve-wracking, but it was also really, really exciting. I was a big fan of you guys, you know. I'm not a big TV watcher.
我记得我们有你在上面是多么兴奋。演员们，你知道的，我们看过你的剧情线，因为我们会看那一集。是的。现在我们可以和你在一起了。你对走进办公区时是什么感觉有什么记忆吗？有的。太吓人了。这让人伤脑筋，但也非常非常令人兴奋。我是你们的超级粉丝，你知道的。我不是个狂热的电视迷。
In general, I just don't tend to be. I don't know why I didn't pick up that habit. I just don't have it. I tend to be more of a comic book reader or frankly a podcast listener and like, you know, I just tend to enjoy a book or something and I was making my living on TV. So I knew the shows, but I was a fan of again that cast of what we call theater actors. I don't know if you all knew that that was Joel's reputation, you know, but like the theater actors and so I was like, great, this is great, like, you know,
总的来说，我往往不是。我不知道为什么我没有养成这个习惯。我只是没有。我往往更喜欢看漫画书，或者坦白说是一个播客听众，就像，你知道的，我倾向于喜欢一书本或者其他什么，而我的生计是通过电视赚来的。所以我知道这些节目，但我又是那种剧组演员的粉丝，我们称之为戏剧演员。我不知道你们是否都知道那是乔尔的名声，你知道的，就像戏剧演员一样，所以我当时想，太棒了，这太棒了，就像，你知道的，
Allison could not have found a better spot for me. Very nervous about it, but then Phyllis was so sweet and we had like, you know, a pretty funny moment. I think there's like a gift for a meme or something running around right now of her, like saying some super awkward racial stuff to Val. And you know, I was a class clown, so I knew I was new there, but
艾莉森不可能为我找到一个更好的位置了。对此非常紧张，但菲利斯太可爱了，我们之间有了一个，你知道的，非常有趣的时刻。我想现在到处流传着一个关于阿米娜的表情包或什么的，关于她对瓦尔说了一些超级尴尬的种族主义言论。你知道的，我是个班上的小丑，所以我知道我是新来的，但是
I was like, I'm sorry, this is hilarious. So we just cracked up and that broke the ice for me, made me feel comfortable and helped me to be what I needed to be, which was funny for the show. And so, yeah, it was a auspicious day for me. Yeah, I don't remember which episode it was, but we were all sitting in a room one time. And I was like, first of all, a, all of these actors are extras on their own show, which I thought was awesome. We talk about it all the time. Like one of the gifts I think of being on the show was humility.
我觉得，不好意思，这太搞笑了。所以我们只是哈哈大笑，这打破了我的僵局，让我感到舒服，并帮助我成为了我需要成为的样子，这对于节目来说很有趣。所以，是的，对我来说这是一个吉祥的日子。是的，我不记得是哪一集了，但有一次我们都坐在一间屋子里。然后我说，首先，a，所有这些演员在他们自己的节目里都是群众演员，我觉得这太棒了。我们一直都在谈论这个。就像我觉得参与这个节目的一大天赋是谦逊。
Yeah. Here, Jenna and I would have a scene and Steve Crowe would be in the background while we're trying to get our scene done. But we were all each other's background. It was really a team effort. I loved that aspect of the show. I just thought I was like, oh, I see what they're doing in here. And it was really cool. Like that to me was one of the coolest parts of it was that, like, literally stars were extras for other stars, which was great. But we were sitting in this room all together. And John was like, I mean,
是的。在这里，珍娜和我有一场戏，而史蒂夫·卡瑞尔会在背景里，而我们正试图拍完我们的戏。但我们都是彼此的背景。这真的是一次团队合作。我喜欢节目的那个方面。我只是觉得，哦，我看到他们在里面做什么了。这真的很酷。对我来说，最酷的部分之一就是，简直是，大明星们为其他大明星当群众演员，这太棒了。但我们都坐在这间屋子里。约翰说，阿米娜，
so you're a choreographer and I guess we had a mutual friend or something like that and he just kind of reached across the water and you know, threw me a life raft and was like, come into this conversation. And I was like, that's super dope. I am with the theater people. And he just gave me an in into the conversation. And I was like, all right, this could be pretty cool. Like everyone here is viby and everyone's being chill.
所以你是个编剧，我想我们有一个共同的朋友什么的，然后他只是隔着一段距离伸出手，你知道的，向我抛出一个救生圈，然后说，加入到这个谈话中来。我当时就觉得，这太酷了。我和戏剧界的人在一起。他只是让我加入了对话。然后我想，好吧，这可能挺酷的。就像这里的每个人都很有氛围，每个人都很随和，
And, you know, let's go, let's do it. Let's have some fun. So it was good. It was a good first couple of episodes. I found a picture of us. We were in one of those vans that was moving us to location. I'm not sure which episode it was, but it's me and you and John.
而且，走吧，我们开始吧。让我们找点乐子。所以这很好。前几集感觉不错。我找到了我们的一张照片。我们在把我们送到外景地的一辆面包车里。我不太确定是哪一集，但里面有我和你还有约翰。
I think I tried to do a selfie before. Like I don't know what I used if I used a digital camera or what, you know? But I sort of took a picture of us and we're just all smiling and beaming, just happy to be at work. And I just love that picture. I'm gonna send it to you. I would love to have that picture.
我想我以前尝试过自拍。就像我不知道我用的是数码相机还是什么，你知道的？但我有点给我们拍了张照片，我们都在微笑，神采奕奕，只是很高兴去上班。我真的很喜欢那张照片。我要把它发给你。我很想拥有那张照片。
That's awesome. Because I was so in my head, you know? Like I was in film school at the time. Like I said, I was doing a lot of my classes remotely. And so I would be, that van would drop me off and I would go right to my trailer and work on something, like whatever it was. So I was like learning something or another or whatever it was. And so it was a very sort of surreal time for me because I knew where I was headed. And this awesome thing
太棒了。因为我当时太沉浸在自己的世界里了，你知道的？就像我当时在读电影学校。就像我说的，我很多课都是远程上的。所以我会，那辆面包车会把我放下，我就会直接去我的拖车上处理一些事情，不管是什么。所以我在学习这样或那样的东西，或者无论是什么。所以对那时的我来说这是一个非常超现实的时刻，因为我知道我要去哪里。而这件棒极了的事情
with the show was happening. And I was like, thanks universe. Like I've been in this town for 10 years, what's going on right now, you know? So it was totally surreal. So I would love to have that picture to add it to my memory bank. Yeah, yeah. Well, let me ask you this question. In Christmas wishes, you wear a gorgeous gown.
随着节目的播出，事情正在发生。我就像，谢谢宇宙。我在这镇上呆了 10 年了，现在到底是怎么回事，你知道的？所以这完全是超现实的。所以我很想要那张照片把它加到我的记忆库里。是的，是的。好吧，我问你这个问题。在《圣诞愿望》里，你穿着一件华丽的礼服。
We spoke about it. How was that? Because it was. Awesome. It was. So I'm a tomboy, like, you know, like I absolutely have always just been like a jeans and t-shirt kind of girl But I love the feminine side as well like I love to dress up I just don't always like to dress myself up
我们谈论过它。感觉怎么样？因为它是。太棒了。是的。所以我是个假小子，就像，你知道的，我绝对一直都只是那种牛仔裤和T恤的女孩。但我也很喜欢女性化的一面，就像我喜欢盛装打扮。我只是不总是喜欢把自己打扮起来。
But so if someone is going to do that I'm game like you can doll me up You can girly me up like I love it. I just need help with it And so when you're in, you know how they are, the wardrobe people love us and they take care of us. And like it is a full blown, self-esteem, confidence booster when you are hanging out with those departments because they are taking care of our emotions, you know, and they, they want us to look good. It's like your hair stylist or whatever, that person that gets into your insecurities and goes, I got you.
但所以如果有人要那样做，我奉陪，你可以把我打扮得漂漂亮亮的，你可以把我打扮成女孩子气的，我喜欢。我只是需要这方面的帮助。所以当你身处其中，你知道他们是怎么样的，服装部门的人很爱我们，他们照顾我们。当你和那些部门在一起时，这完全是一种自我价值和自信的提升，因为他们在照顾我们的情绪，你知道的，而且他们，他们希望我们看起来很好。就像你的发型师或者别的什么，那个能看透你的不安全感并对你说，我懂你的人。
And I'm going to make you look good. I got you. You know, and that's what they did. They literally gave me the confidence to go onto this massive TV show with all of you amazing actors and, you know, who had totally done this remarkable thing in your careers. And here comes this new girl and she's gonna play a love interest
我会让你看起来很棒的。我罩着你。你知道的，这就是他们所做的。他们确实给了我信心，让我能和你们所有这些优秀的演员一起走进这个巨大的电视剧里，你知道的，你们在职业生涯中完全做过这件了不起的事情。然后来了这个新女孩，她要扮演一个恋爱对象
to a super popular character on the show and those wardrobe people were like, I got you, I got you. And they found a great color and a great fitting dress, you know, and hid my pooch. Everything was. Oh stop, you look phenomenal, you look phenomenal. I appreciate it. I loved the scene though. We're Valendero
给剧中一个超级受欢迎的角色，而那些服装部门的人就像，我罩着你，我罩着你。他们找到了一种很棒的颜色和一件很合身的礼服，你知道的，还遮住了我的小肚子。一切都是。哦，别说了，你看起来太惊艳了，你看起来太惊艳了。我很感激。不过我喜欢那个场景。我们是瓦尔和达里尔
are sort of having this sidebar and Val goes, you said dress up and he goes, yeah, I was thinking like a sweater and Val goes a sweater. What am I? Your grandson? She was like, she was so pissed, but you did such a great job portraying like so many. There's so many layers of emotion happening right there. And I thought I was a great scene. Yeah, me too, I remember that one. Yeah, and just what a cute and clever little storyline too. Because Val, you know, she really is that every woman, you know, she's like working in the warehouse, but I love that character because she was smart.
有点在进行这个旁敲侧击，然后瓦尔说，你说了盛装打扮，他接着说，对，我以为是像毛衣之类的，瓦尔说毛衣。我是谁？你孙子吗？她就像，她气炸了，但你扮演得太棒了，演绎了那么多。那里有很多层情感同时发生。我觉得那是一场很棒的戏。是的，我也是，我还记得那一场。是的，而且剧情线也是多么可爱和聪明。因为瓦尔，你知道的，她真的是那种凡人女性，你知道的，她在仓库工作，但我很喜欢这个角色，因为她很聪明。
And she maybe didn't have opportunities like whatever. Like she didn't graduate from Harvard or Yale or something like this, but that didn't mean she wasn't smart because she had risen to the top of her profession. And she came in and she was very serious. And I loved that juxtaposition. I loved playing the straight man to all of the silliness that was in there.
她可能没有像其他人那样的机会。就像她没有从哈佛、耶鲁或类似的名校毕业，但这并不意味着她不聪明，因为她已经晋升到她职业生涯的顶峰。她走进来时非常严肃。我喜欢这种并列。我喜欢在里面所有的愚蠢中扮演冷静的人。
Frankly, I could not have competed with the silliness that was in there. Frankly, I could not have competed with the silliness that was in there. Those guys were all, oh my goodness. Those guys were just, they're funny guys. They're all, and so if I tried to dip into that arena, I was like, yeah, no, I think I'm gonna go this way. And it just seemed like the best thing to do is to keep her as the straight man.
坦白说，我无法与里面那些愚蠢竞争。坦白说，我无法与里面那些愚蠢竞争。那些家伙全都是，哦天哪。那些家伙只是，他们都是有趣的人。所以如果我试图涉足那个领域，我会觉得，好吧，不，我想我还是走这条路吧。这似乎是最好的做法，就是保持她作为清醒冷静的角色。
And as sort of like, she's a every woman. And I really enjoyed that. My mentor, one of them, Charlene Woodard, she's on pose and everything else, original Broadway cast of Aint Miss Behave, and like, she's ridiculous. She's amazing. And I call her up every now and again, and I go, help me please. And she goes, Meena, we play regular people. And she said that to me one day, and I went, okay, okay, I totally get that. And I'm here for that. We play regular people and I'm down for that. I'm down to be the every woman for the people.
而且有点像，她是一个普通女性。我真的很喜欢这一点。我的导师之一，查琳·伍达德，她出演过《姿态》和其他一切，百老汇原版《Ain't Misbehavin'》的演员，简直离谱。她太棒了。我时不时会给她打电话，说，请帮帮我。然后她说，阿米娜，我们扮演的是普通人。她有一天对我说过这句话，然后我想，好的，好的，我完全明白了。我为此而来。我们扮演普通人，我接受这一点。我愿意做大众眼中的那个普通女性。
And that's who I think Val was. And so I was stoked on that character and stoked that she got to dress up like that. Because I think that everybody, the every man, can relate to that. Yeah. And I think that's why, the every man can relate to that. Yeah. I think that's why people like that character. She endures, Bows is a good character, well-written. Yeah.
我想瓦尔就是那样的人。所以我对那个角色很兴奋，也很高兴她能那样盛装打扮。因为我认为每个人，普通人，都能对此产生共鸣。是的。我认为这就是为什么，普通人能对此产生共鸣。是的。我想这就是人们喜欢那个角色的原因。她经受住了考验，瓦尔是一个好角色，写得很好。是的。
And performed. Thank you. I appreciate that. Thank you. Yeah, those writers were killers, weren't they? So, I mean, I know you talked a little bit about this earlier, but was there a moment where you broke? Because we would all crack up in scenes. And I don't know if there's, if you have a strong memory of it was there a moment where you broke? Because we would all crack up in scenes.
而且表演得很精彩。谢谢。我很感激。谢谢。是的，那些编剧太厉害了，不是吗？所以，阿米娜，我知道你刚才稍微谈到了这一点，但有没有哪一个瞬间你笑场了？因为我们在拍戏时都会笑场。我不知道，如果你有深刻的记忆，有没有哪一个瞬间你笑场了？因为我们在拍戏时都会笑场。
And I don't know if there is, if you have a strong memory of it, like a scene where you broke. Yeah. That was the moment I was saying, we're Phyllis and I were talking to, she was saying some really silly racial s*** to me, which is not her at all. And she could barely get those lines out. And she just broke me. Because like I said, I'm a class clown.
我不知道，如果你有深刻的记忆，比如你笑场的那场戏。是的。那就是我刚才说的那一刻，我和菲利斯在交谈，她对我说了一些非常愚蠢的种族主义脏话，这根本不是她平时会说的话。她几乎说不出那些台词。她把我逗笑了。因为就像我说的，我是个班上的小丑。
I was, I literally was voted class clown. Like I am make, you know, funny. That's I love to just hang in comedy and she just cracked me up watching. I'm just gonna say it. I'm just gonna speak very plainly, watching a middle age, very sweet white woman and watching her have to deliver those lines that the writers had written for her. The whole scene was cracking me up. Phyllis, the actress, the character Phyllis, saying it to vowel the character, the whole thing cracked me up. And we died laughing.
我曾，我 literalmente 被评选为班上的小丑。就像我总是，你知道的，搞笑。那就是我喜欢沉浸在喜剧中，而看着她，我只想说出来。我只想直白地说，看着一个中年、非常甜蜜的白人女性，看着她不得不说出编剧为她写那些台词。整个场景都把我逗笑了。菲利斯，那个演员，菲利斯这个角色，对瓦尔那个角色说，整件事都把我逗笑了。我们笑得死去活来。
And I think somebody made it into a meme. Well, I found him in the bloopers. And you guys could not get through it. It was just ridiculous. But that's one of my favorite things is finding all these moments in the bloopers and just seeing how much joy and laughter we had every day. Yeah. Yeah. It was it was really fun. Do people recognize you as Val and come up to you?
我想有人把它做成了表情包。好吧，我在花絮里找到了。而你们根本无法坚持拍完。简直太荒谬了。但这是我最喜欢的事情之一，就是在花絮里找到所有这些时刻，看到我们每天拥有多少快乐和笑声。是的。是的。真的很搞笑。人们会认出你是瓦尔并走过来找你吗？
They do. The show is that popular. You guys killed it. The show is that popular that even I get recognized a lot. I'm super grateful, you know, I believe artists are public servants and so, you know, you just want to honor them and because they're honoring you and and and know that like that fan base is the reason why you get paid and is the reason why you eat have clothes on your back, all of it. And so I'm super grateful for it. I've cut my hair. I know no one can see it, but I've totally cut off all my hair. And yes, the recognition did go down from there,
会的。这部剧太火了。你们太棒了。这部剧太火了，以至于连我也会经常被认出来。我超级感激，你知道的，我相信艺术家是公众的公仆，所以，你知道的，你只想向他们致敬，因为他们在向你致敬，并且知道，这个粉丝群体就是你拿到报酬的原因，也是你吃得上饭、穿得起衣服的原因，一切的一切。所以我对此超级感激。我剪了头发。我知道没人能看到，但我真的把所有的头发都剪掉了。是的，从那以后被认出来的频率确实下降了，
but I've been kind of doing these sort of, you know, public hits lately that have been putting me out there with short hair. So it's kind of ticked up again that people recognizing me. But more what I get is you look awfully familiar. Where do I know you from? Like of course, that kind of thing.
但我最近一直在做这种，你知道的，会让我在短发造型下频频公开露面的通告。所以认出我的人又有点变多了。但更多的时候我听到的是，你看起来眼熟得可怕。我在哪见过你？就像当然，那种情况。
And now a days I just go, I used to be a TV actor and I keep it moving, you know, and let them, you know, because I don't want to be coy, I don't want to, but I also don't want to be like, okay, let me give you my resume, you know, anything like that. You know, but yeah, I'm grateful for it. Oh, we get, you look like an older version of that lady
现在我只是说，我曾经是个电视演员，然后我就继续往前走，你知道的，让他们，你知道的，因为我不想遮遮掩掩，我不想，但我也绝不想表现得像，好吧，让我给你我的简历，你知道的，诸如此类的事情。你知道的，但是的，我很感激。哦，我们得到的是，你看起来像《办公室》里那个女士的年长版。
on the office. And we both say we are the older version. That's awesome. That's awesome. Seriously, that's like, that's a holiday treat. That's a gift. It is. We're forever frozen in time, you know, but time marches on. It sure does. Well, this was just an absolute delight. I love that we got to reconnect with you. Am Well, this was just an absolute delight. I love that we got to reconnect
我们两个都说我们就是年长版。这太棒了。太棒了。说真的，这就像，这是一种节日的款待。这是一份礼物。确实如此。我们永远被定格在时间里，你知道的，但时间在流逝。确实如此。好吧，这简直是一大乐事。我很高兴我们能重新联系到你。阿米娜，好吧，这简直是一大乐事。我很高兴我们能重新联系
with you Amina. This was so awesome. Thank you, Jenna and Angel, I really appreciate you both, and it's lovely to reconnect with you both. This is awesome. I appreciate this very much. Now, I know you can't share about your secret project that you're doing right now, but is there anything that you can share about? Sure, listeners? Yeah, you know, everybody, you know, since I'm leaving the office and kind of leaving Hollywood, I've been really focused on being a director. That's kind of what I think my ultimate passion has always been.
到你，阿米娜。这太棒了。谢谢你，珍娜和安吉拉，我真的很感激你们俩，很高兴能和你们俩重新联系。这太棒了。我非常感激。现在，我知道你不能分享你现在正在做的秘密项目，但有什么是你可以分享的吗？当然，听众朋友们？是的，你知道的，各位，你知道的，自从我离开《办公室》并且有点离开好莱坞以来，我一直专注于成为一名导演。这差不多是我认为我的终极热情所在。
And so I'm uniting those skills and music dance acting. So my show's I'm sort of a spectacle director with like a real strong sense of storytelling. So I just open to show at Seattle Rep. It's called Lydia and the troll and I'm very excited about it because it's about a performer who is who doesn't look right and doesn't do all the things right. And she's always standing in the back but she deserves to be in the front and she's uh she doesn't believe in herself and this troll comes along and it's like I'll steal that body.'ll take that body from you. If you don't want it to just get this confidence It really does have like world, you know, big potential
所以我将这些技能与音乐、舞蹈、表演结合起来。所以我的节目，我有点像一个具有强烈叙事感的奇观导演。所以我刚刚在西雅图剧团推出了一档节目。它叫《莉迪亚与巨魔》，我对此非常兴奋，因为它是关于一个表演者，她看起来不对劲，而且没有把所有事情都做好。她总是站在后面，但她理应站在前面，而且她，她不相信自己，然后这个巨魔出现了，就像我会偷走那个身体。我会把那个身体从你身上拿走。如果你不想只获得自信
And so I'm really stoked because it gets to use all of my skills dance music acting all together and I'm a full-time director for Disney I did a project called Disney Dreamers Academy, which was we take a hundred high school kids and bring them into Disney and we mentor them. And that is by far the best program that I've done at Disney is connecting them with Imagineers, connecting them with animal science people and getting them over to, you know, wherever, like got them over to the Star Cruiser, the Star Wars Galactic Star Cruiser, which was my main project and, you know, got the kids into outer space essentially.
所以真的有很大的潜力，你知道的。所以我超级兴奋，因为它用到了我所有的技能——舞蹈、音乐、表演，全部结合在一起。我是迪士尼的全职导演，我做了一个名为“迪士尼梦想家学院”的项目，我们招收一百名高中生并将他们带到迪士尼，我们指导他们。这绝对是我在迪士尼做过的最好的项目，将他们与幻想工程师联系起来，将他们与动物科学人员联系起来，并让他们去，你知道的，无论哪里，比如把他们带到星舰巡航舰，星球大战银河星舰，这是我的主要项目，你知道的，基本上把孩子们送到了外太空。
And that has been the most fulfilling thing that I've done at Disney so far. But if people are wondering where I disappeared to, I didn't. I am a lifer, like we said, down the line. That's why. Yeah, and so I'm a director now, and I'm just doing my thing, just living, just being an artist is out here
这到目前为止是我在迪士尼做过的最有成就感的事情。但如果人们想知道我消失到哪里去了，我没有。我是一生都献给艺术的人，就像我们说的，从一而终。这就是原因。是的，所以我现在是一名导演，我只是在做我自己的事，生活着，作为一个艺术家在这个世界上，只是在做这件事。
in these streets, just doing it. Love it. Awesome, awesome. Amina, we want to have you back. We're going to hit you out because we're going to have questions for some of your other episodes. I'd love it because this has been a real treat. And thank you.
太棒了。太棒了，太棒了。阿米娜，我们想让你再来。我们会找你的，因为我们对你的其他剧集还有问题。我很乐意，因为这真的是一次美妙的体验。谢谢你。
I'm grateful that you've had me here. I appreciate it very much. Thank you so much. So much. Awesome. Awesome. How much do you love Amina? She's the coolest person.
我很感激你能邀请我来。我非常感谢。非常感谢。非常感谢。太棒了。太棒了。你有多喜欢阿米娜？她是最酷的人。
She's super cool. And very, I thought, very inspiring. I love the way she talks about being an artist and our role in the world. And I can't wait to hit her up for some future episodes because there's going to be a few I want to talk to her about. Hello, pull party. Mm-hmm. Well, let's get into this episode.
她超级酷。而且我认为非常鼓舞人心。我喜欢她谈论作为一名艺术家以及我们在世界上的角色的方式。我迫不及待地想在未来的剧集中找她，因为有几集我想和她聊聊。你好，泳池派对。嗯哼。好吧，我们进入这一集吧。
It's going to start with a close-up shot of a bunch of dolls. They're like Christmas carolers. And Andy is singing off-camera in falsetto. We reveal to see him dress to Santa, and he's going to declare that he is the first Santa to make holiday wishes come true. Well, Angela, we got some fan mail about those singing dolls. They are, in fact, carolers. And Jeremy V from Harrisburg, Pennsylvania, said, those are Briar's choice figurines. They are Christmas carol figurines made in Pennsylvania.
它将以一堆娃娃的特写镜头开始。它们就像圣诞报童。而安吉拉在画外用假声唱歌。镜头拉开，我们看到他穿着圣诞老人的衣服，他将宣布他是第一个让节日愿望成真的圣诞老人。好吧，安吉拉，我们收到了一些关于那些唱歌娃娃的粉丝信。它们实际上是报童。来自宾夕法尼亚州哈里斯堡的杰里米·V说，那些是布赖尔精选小雕像。它们是宾夕法尼亚州制作的圣诞报童小雕像。
And Jeremy said, I really want to shout them out because the office did a fantastic job adding a little bit of local Pennsylvania flavor to the Christmas wishes episode this season. While I looked into these Angela, these dolls were created by Joyce Byers, which also happens to be the name of the character that would know in a writer plays and stranger things. Oh, but this Joyce spires started making handmade carol or decorations just for her own home, just for Christmas and people would come over for Christmas parties and they loved them.
杰里米说，我真的很想大声称赞他们，因为《办公室》在为本季的《圣诞愿望》这一集增添一点宾夕法尼亚州的本土风情方面做得非常出色。安吉拉，我研究了一下，这些娃娃是由乔伊斯·拜尔斯创造的，这也恰好是我们在《怪奇物语》中认识的编剧扮演的角色的名字。哦，但这位乔伊斯·拜尔斯开始制作手工报童装饰品只是为了她自己的家，只是为了圣诞节，人们来参加圣诞派对时都很喜欢它们。
And they started asking her for some that they could give away as gifts. They eventually became so popular she started selling them in local shops. And I mean, now it's a whole business. The whole family isn't on it. Her husband, her sons, they produce over 500,000 carolers each year, and the company donates a large portion of their profits to local, national, and international charities. I love this. She was so crafty, and now she has a whole business. Well, I have a
他们开始向她索要一些可以作为礼物送人的东西。它们最终变得如此受欢迎，以至于她开始在当地商店出售它们。我的意思是，现在它成了一项大生意。整个家族都参与进来了。她的丈夫、她的儿子们，每年生产超过 50 万个报童，而且公司将很大一部分利润捐给当地、国家和国际慈善机构。我太喜欢这个了。她曾经那么心灵手巧，现在她拥有了一整个大生意。好吧，我有一个
fun little tidbit about this cold open. Speaking of caroling, how's that for transition, Jenna? I love a good transition. I know you do. There was a candy bag alt for this cold open that would have started like this. I'm just going to read you the first few lines. Okay. Okay. It was a rapid fire series of talking heads. Dwight kicks it off. Dwight, I knew this day would come. Jim, I think I blocked it from my mind. Angela, it actually makes me like Christmas less. Me, Christmas. Andy talking head.
关于这个冷开场的好玩小八卦。说到报童，这个转场怎么样，珍娜？我喜欢好的转场。我知道你喜欢。这个冷开场有一个糖果包的备用版本，它是这样开始的。我只读前几行给你听。好的。好的。这是一系列快节奏的谈话头。德怀特开了个头。德怀特，我知道这一天会到来。吉姆，我想我把它从脑子里屏蔽了。安吉拉，这实际上让我更不喜欢圣诞节了。我，圣诞节。安吉拉谈话头。
Andy is super excited. He has a reindeer antler hat on. Andy says, I'm the boss now. We're Christmas caroling bitches. So this was like a Christmas caroling alternate cold open where we're all Christmas caroling. Yes, and there's rehearsals and the whole group is in the warehouse and Andy is working on different songs and
安吉拉超级兴奋。他戴着驯鹿鹿角帽子。安吉拉说，我现在是老板了。我们是去唱圣诞颂歌的混蛋们。所以这是一个圣诞颂歌的备用冷开场，我们都在唱圣诞颂歌。是的，有排练，整个团队都在仓库里，安吉拉在研究不同的歌曲，
getting really like bossy about it. It was hilarious, but that was the alt. And then it would go into the holiday wishes conference room scene. But instead, I think there was just so much in that conference room scene, they split it up and made part of it a cold open. Yes. And this brings us to how the cold open starts, right? And he's in the conference room.
并且对此变得真的很像老板一样专横。这太搞笑了，但那是备用版本。然后就会切入节日愿望会议室的场景。但相反，我想会议室里的内容实在是太多了，他们把它拆分了一部分做成冷开场。是的。这就带来了冷开场的开始方式，对吧？他在会议室里。
He is trying unsuccessfully to get everyone excited about these holiday wishes. And that is a trigger for Stanley. Yes. Stanley goes on a very big rant about how he is sick and tired of themed Christmas parties. And he lists all the parties and all the themes that he has had to endure at Dunder Mifflin. When he says Honolulu Christmas that pans to me and I roll my eyes, that was improvised, guys. I just knew... I looked in the script, Angela. I wanted to see. Yeah, I just figured my character would be kind of commiserating with Stanley, right?
他试图让每个人对这些节日愿望感到兴奋，但没有成功。这成了斯坦利的导火索。是的。斯坦利发表了一番长篇大论，谈到他如何厌倦了主题圣诞派对。他列出了他在邓德米夫林忍受过的所有派对和所有主题。当他说檀香山圣诞节时，镜头转向我，我翻了个白眼，那是即兴发挥的，伙计们。我只是知道……我在剧本里找了，安吉拉。我想看看。是的，我只是觉得我的角色会有点同情斯坦利，对吧？
She just wants Christmas as Christmas. I love that. Well, you know, Jim has a talking head where he says he got Stanley tickets to see Lewis Black for his birthday. Yeah. We have a fan catch from Rachel L in Anaheim, California. What do you got, Rachel?
她只想要真正的圣诞节。我太喜欢这个了。好吧，你知道，吉姆有一个谈话头，他说他送给斯坦利去看路易斯·布莱克的票作为生日礼物。是的。我们收到了来自加利福尼亚州阿纳海姆的雷切尔·L的粉丝抓包。你有什么发现，雷切尔？
Rachel noticed that in season nine, episode eight, when Jim tries to convince Stanley and Phyllis to cover for him while he's in Philadelphia, Jim and Stanley say they don't even know each other's birthdays because as Stanley claims, they're not friends. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. So here, Jim knew his birthday, but in season nine, apparently, Jim doesn't. Well, the episode is going to open with the gang still in the conference room, and he is
雷切尔注意到，在第九季第八集里，当吉姆试图说服斯坦利和菲利斯在他身在费城期间帮他顶班时，吉姆和斯坦利说他们甚至不知道彼此的生日，正如斯坦利所说，他们不是朋友。嗯哼。嗯哼。所以在这里，吉姆知道他的生日，但在第九季里，显然吉姆不知道。好吧，这一集开场时大家还在会议室里，他
going over everyone's wish list, saying who's wishes got fulfilled. There's a whole bunch. There's also more and deleted scenes, and I thought I could break them down for you. Oh, this is great, because we got fan mail from Jaden P. and Phoenix, Arizona, who said, I've always wondered if there were more wishes. I would particularly like to know what Crete asked for. Okay, Jaden, I got you.
在检查每个人的愿望清单，说谁的愿望实现了。有一大堆。还有更多被删减的片段，我想我可以为你剖析它们。哦，这太棒了，因为我们收到了来自亚利桑那州菲尼克斯的杰登·P的粉丝信，他说，我一直想知道是否还有更多的愿望。我特别想知道克里德许了什么愿。好吧，杰登，包在我身上。
Here's how it breaks down. First I'll do everything that made the episode, and then I'll tell you what's in deleted scenes. Meredith gets a car right home at the end of the night. Dwight wants to know what about his wish where they don't have to attend meetings that degrade their sense of adulthood, and he said no can do, but I did get you an acre of land on the moon. Dwight is so happy about this. It's on the light side, it's by the sea of tranquility. This is a big win. Yeah, Andy's biggest wish is that everyone would be nice
情况是这样的。首先我会说所有进入正片的片段，然后我会告诉你删减片段里有什么。梅雷迪思在派对结束时得到了顺风车回家。德怀特想知道他的愿望怎么样，就是不用参加那些贬低他们成年感的会议，他说不行，但我确实为你赢得了月球上一英亩的土地。德怀特对此超级高兴。它在光面，在静海附近。这是一个巨大的胜利。是的。安吉拉最大的愿望是每个人都能对他的女朋友杰西卡好一点。
to his girlfriend, Jessica. And from deleted scenes, Kevin, hands Andy a cheesecake factory menu with little post-it note tabs specifically on different items. Creed, hands Andy a piece of paper, Andy reads it and then hands Creed $20. Okay. Kelly hands Andy multiple pages fully typed of her wishes. There's like three or four pages. And then Ryan has a wish and Andy's going to try to grant it. Jenna, this is such a dad moment. Here's what it said in this script. Andy says, Ryan, for your holiday wish, you wanted 10 sick days. Ryan said, yeah, but I'd be satisfied with eight.
从删减片段来看，凯文递给安吉拉一本芝士蛋糕工厂的菜单，上面有针对不同项目的彩色便签标签。克里德递给安吉拉一张纸，安吉拉读了然后递给克里德 20 美元。好吧。凯莉递给安吉拉几页完全打印出来的愿望。大概有三四页。然后瑞安有一个愿望，安吉拉要试着满足它。珍娜，这真是太父亲时刻了。剧本上是这么写的。安吉拉说，瑞安，作为你的节日愿望，你想要 10 天病假。瑞安说，行吧，但我有八天就满足了。
And Andy says, well, I'll do you one better. Ryan's like nine. Andy says, I got you health insurance. And Ryan goes, oh, neat. And Andy goes, yeah, right? But with great perks, come great responsibility. So I'm going to be expecting a lot more from you. No more zoning out in your office.
安吉拉说，好吧，我给你个更好的。瑞安说九天？安吉拉说，我给你办了健康保险。然后瑞安说，哦，整洁。安吉拉说，是吧，对吧？但伴随着巨大的福利而来的，是巨大的责任。所以我对你会有更多的期望。不要再在办公室里走神了。
And Ryan's like, oh, great. And BJ plays it so great. The look of disappointment on Ryan's face when he finds out he gets health insurance, which is a good thing. It was very funny. Well, I have a really fun fan catch for this conference room scene.
然后瑞安说，哦，太棒了。BJ 演得太棒了。当瑞安发现自己得到了健康保险——这是一件好事时，脸上流露出失望的表情。这非常搞笑。好吧，我为这个会议室场景准备了一个非常有趣的粉丝抓包。
It came in from Walker M in Grand Rapids, Minnesota. This is a catch from Walker's two-year-old son, Roman. Two-year-old? Did you say two-year-old? Yes, two years old. This is Roman's catch. You can see Kelly in the background in a sparkly outfit. And Roman pointed at her and said, look, dad, a princess.
它来自明尼苏达州大急流城的沃克·M。这是沃克两岁儿子罗曼的抓包。两岁？你刚才说两岁？是的，两岁。这是罗曼抓到的。你可以看到凯莉在背景里穿着闪亮的衣服。罗曼指着她对爸爸说，看，爸爸，是个公主。
And Walker said he was so proud that he had spotted a real princess in the background of the show. Is that the sweetest thing? So sweet. We have to share that with Mindy. Well, I know she would love that. Well, guess what? This is my favorite Kelly outfit for any holiday. The red skirt with the silk like tank top and the shimmery sparkly jacket. I love this holiday outfit. I almost always would wear what Kelly is wearing in a holiday episode. Outside of Pam's vintage sweater,
沃克说，他为自己能在剧集背景里发现一个真正的公主而感到骄傲。这不是最甜蜜的事吗？太甜了。我们必须和敏迪分享这个。好吧，我知道她会喜欢这个。好吧，你猜怎么着？这是我最喜欢的凯莉在任何假期的服装。红色裙子搭配丝绸质感的背心和闪闪发光的夹克。我太喜欢这套节日服装了。我几乎总是会穿凯利在节日剧集中穿的衣服。除了潘的复古毛衣，
which is my number one, then it just everything Kelly ever wore. I just love it for a holiday party. She does the best job, I think. I agree. You love to dress up for a holiday party. Don't get me started. We wrote about it in our book, but no one goes on theme more than you do of anyone I know. That's true. So after the conference room scene, there is a talking head where we're going to learn a little bit, I don't know about where Erin is at with Jessica, right? She says she hasn't met her yet, but she loves Jessica. They don't even need to meet. She should stay home. Yes. Oh no. And then Kelly's going to come up to reception and say, listen, I'll be mean to Jessica if you want me to,
这是我的首选，然后就是凯莉穿过的一切。我太喜欢它在节日派对上的效果了。我觉得她做得最好。我同意。你喜欢为节日派对盛装打扮。别让我打开话匣子。我们在书里写过这个，但没有人比你更注重派对主题了，这是我认识的人里数一数二的。确实如此。所以会议室场景之后，有一个谈话头，我们会了解到一点，我不知道艾琳对杰西卡是什么态度，对吧？她说她还没见过她，但她爱杰西卡。他们甚至不需要见面。她应该呆在家里。是的。哦不。然后凯莉会走到前台说，听着，如果你想的话，我对杰西卡刻薄点也没关系，
because I was actually planning on it anyway, which is amazing. Kelly is one of those friends where they're like, do we like them? And if you're like, no, they're like, got it. Like, wait, you don't even know them. All right, I have a possibly amazing, possibly super lame background catch of reception desk.
因为我本来就打算这么做，这太棒了。凯莉就是那种朋友，他们会说，我们喜欢他们吗？如果你说不，他们就会说，懂了。等等，你甚至不认识他们。好吧，我有一个可能很棒，可能超级烂的前台背景抓包。
Wait, a sell me. Well, there is a great shot of the message Sorter on Aaron's desk and I notice that everyone in the office shares a slot with another person except for two people. Tell me all the slides. All right. So Andy, he has his own slot. Mixense, he's the manager, right? Yeah, he's the boss. So then, Pam, Jim and Dwight share a slot. Mixense, same desk clump, I guess.
等等，卖关子吗？好吧，艾琳桌上的信件分拣器有一个很棒的镜头，我注意到办公室里的每个人都和另一个人共用一个格子，除了两个人。告诉我所有的格子。好的。所以，安吉拉，他有自己的格子。有道理，他是经理，对吧？是的，他是老板。然后，潘、吉姆和德怀特共用一个格子。有道理，同一组办公桌，我猜。
Then, Phyllis Stanley Creed share a slot. Angela Oscar Kevin, Kelly Ryan Toby, Meredith, has a slot all to herself. How many messages is she getting? I mean, so few. So many. So few. But she, I mean, I'm thinking like there are so many
然后，菲利斯、斯坦利、克里德共用一个格子。安吉拉、奥斯卡、凯文，凯莉、瑞安、托比，梅雷迪思，自己独占一个格子。她到底收到了多少信件？我的意思是，这么少。这么多。这么少。但她，我的意思是，我想有很多
quality control issues that Meredith just needed her own slot for messages. And I will also say, no slot for Darryl. Oh, I don't know how he gets his messages, but he is not slotted. I love these kind of background details. Do you know I obsess about them? Okay, so amazing or lame.
质量控制问题，以至于梅雷迪思需要她自己的格子来收信。我还要说，达里尔没有格子。哦，我不知道他是怎么收到信的，但他没有格子。我喜欢这种背景细节。你知道我对它们痴迷吗？好吧，很棒还是烂透了？
I say amazing. Thank you. Well, Robert California is gonna arrive. And Jenna, I just have a question for you. Yeah, what time do you think the party starts at Dundermeflin? Well, I sure hope it's a daytime party because there are a series of episodes now
我说很棒。谢谢。好吧，罗伯特·加利福尼亚要到了。珍娜，我只想问你一个问题。是的，你觉得邓德米夫林的派对几点开始？好吧，我真希望这是一个白天派对，因为现在有一系列剧集
where Jim is constantly doing things outside of work after hours with his wife and like new baby and toddler at home. They're just a string of episodes with these extracurriculars. So I'm really hoping that this is an afternoon party. I know it's going to end at night because we're going to see night later. But this is my hope. Why do you ask?
吉姆经常在工作时间之外与他的妻子以及家里的新宝宝和幼儿一起做各种事情。有一连串剧集都是这些课外活动。所以我真的希望这是一个下午的派对。我知道它会以夜晚结束，因为我们稍后会看到夜晚。但这是我的希望。你为什么这么问？
Well, you won't be disappointed. I'll tell you that. But just more specifically, let's really dial it in here. What time do you think the bar opens at your holiday Christmas party? Three. There was more to the scene, and Robert California, he's gonna let us know when he thinks the party should start. I'm gonna read you what it said in the script.
嗯，你不会失望的。我只能这么告诉你。但更具体地说，让我们真正仔细想想。你觉得你们公司的圣诞派对酒吧几点开门？三点。这个场景还有更多内容，罗伯特·加利福尼亚，他会让我们知道他觉得派对应该几点开始。我读一下剧本上是怎么写的。
Okay. Robert says, where can I get a drink? And Andy goes, oh, well, we thought we wouldn't put the alcohol out till 11 a.m. It's just common decency. And Robert goes, par for the course. Par for the frickin' course. I'll be in the party room having a cookie until 11.
好的。罗伯特说，我在哪能弄到一杯饮料？然后安吉拉说，哦，嗯，我们觉得我们不会在上午 11 点之前把酒拿出来。这是基本的人情礼貌。然后罗伯特说，这很正常。真他妈太正常了。我会在派对室吃饼干，直到 11 点。
11! 11 a.m. they set the booze out. Are you crazy? They're waiting till 11. Yeah. So they were going to wait till 11. Yeah, we're gonna wait till 11. 11? That's when the party starts. I could not believe that. Wow, this explains why people get so trash. Exactly.
11 点！他们上午 11 点才把酒拿出来。你们疯了吗？他们要等到 11 点。是的，他们打算等到 11 点。是的，我们要等到 11 点。11 点？派对就是那时候开始的。我简直不敢相信。哇，这就解释了为什么人们喝得那么烂醉如泥了。没错。
They've been drinking since 11. Robert is gonna get a giant bear hug from Kevin. He says he feels like a kitten being cradled by a gorilla. That hug was hilarious to me. Brian just scooped him up. Robert says he's actually looking forward to the Dunderman Flynn party because the corporate party was awful.
他们从 11 点就开始喝了。罗伯特将得到凯文的一个大大的熊抱。他说他感觉自己像是一只被大猩猩搂在怀里的小猫。那个拥抱对我来说太搞笑了。布赖恩直接把他抱了起来。罗伯特说他其实很期待邓德米夫林的派对，因为公司的派对太糟糕了。
I guess he's really not a fan of the Black Eyed Peas. And Ryan I think felt seen in this moment. Yes. We're gonna notice that Robert is in, I thought it was like pajamas honestly I guess Andy goes on to say it's a track suit But he's looking a little disheveled and there was a talking head that was deleted where Robert describes the mood he is in I have to read this to you. It just made me laugh now Jenna. It was written with lots of dot dot dots
我想他真的不是黑眼豆豆乐队的粉丝。我想瑞安在这个时刻感同身受。是的。我们会注意到罗伯特穿着，我以为那是睡衣，老实说，我猜安吉拉接着说是运动服，但他看起来有点衣衫不整，还有一个被删减的谈话头，罗伯特在其中描述了他的心情。我必须读给你听。它现在让我笑了，珍娜。它是用很多省略号写的
It was written with parentheses that say, give a long pause here. Lapse awkwardly. Okay, so get ready for some big pauses and some awkwardness. I'm ready. Here was Robert's deleted talking head. About the state of mind he's in. Okay.
它写着括号，上面写着“在这里做长时间的停顿。尴尬地停顿一下”。好吧，准备好迎接一些长时间的停顿和尴尬吧。我准备好了。这是罗伯特被删减的谈话头。关于他的心境。好的。
Not destroyed. No. Not destructive. Quite off-kilter? Sure. But that's too vague. Erratic. Darkly erratic. That's my mood. Yeah, and then he just looks at the camera for a long time. I was like, oh crap, Robert, Robert is gonna be spiraling. Well, if I know James Fader, he has a document for Robert, California, in the same way that I had my Pam document. And I think this darkly erratic went in the same way that I had my PAM document. And I think this darkly erratic went in the document and we're gonna see that play out over the next few episodes
没毁掉。不。不是毁了。挺古怪的？当然。但那太模糊了。喜怒无常。阴暗地喜怒无常。这就是我的心情。对，然后他对着镜头看了好久。当时我想，哦糟了，罗伯特，罗伯特又要陷入精神崩溃了。好吧，如果我了解詹姆斯·费德尔，他为罗伯特·加利福尼亚准备了一份人物档案，就像我当初为帕姆准备档案一样。而且我认为这种阴暗的喜怒无常也记录在那份档案里，我们会在接下来的几集里看到这如何发展
as he unravels from his divorce. Well, next up, Andy is gonna call Jim and Dwight into his office. Yes, and you might have been wondering, where did Robert go? He was standing right there. He was just talking to all of them. It is because the deleted scene where he goes in the conference room to eat a cookie until the bar opens. Aha. Well, Andy is going to take off his Santa hat and put on his hard ass hat because
随着他的离婚而逐渐崩溃。好，接下来，安迪要把吉姆和德怀特叫进他的办公室。是的，你可能一直在想，罗伯特去哪儿了？他刚刚就站在那儿。他刚才还在跟所有人说话。这是因为删减了一个镜头，他去会议室吃饼干，直到酒吧开门。啊哈。好吧，安迪要摘下他的圣诞帽，换上他的严厉老板帽，因为
there are some serious issues to discuss. The hat is literally a pair of buttocks with the words hardass on them. Would you like to know what standards and practices had to say about the hat? I would love to. Okay. Well, Steve Burgess shared with me how this hardass hat went down. It began with an email from standards and practices which said, please email me a photo of the, quote,
有一些严肃的问题要讨论。这顶帽子实际上是一对屁股，上面写着“严厉老板”几个字。你想知道标准与实践部门对这顶帽子有什么评价吗？我很想知道。好的。好吧，史蒂夫·伯吉斯跟我分享了这顶“严厉老板”帽是怎么通过的。它始于标准与实践部门的一封邮件，上面写着：请发给我一张“塑料屁股棒球帽”的照片，供我审查。
plastic butt baseball cap for my review. So, Steve Burgess sent over two photos. There were two different options. And he said, here are two versions of the hat. They're similar, but different sizes. So, there was one with larger buttocks and one was smaller. Our standards and practices rep was named Andrew, and Andrew had to run this all the way up to his boss.
于是，史蒂夫·伯吉斯发了两张照片过去。有两个不同的选项。他说，这是帽子的两个版本。它们很相似，但尺寸不同。所以，有一个屁股比较大的，还有一个比较小的。我们的标准与实践代表名叫安德鲁，安德鲁不得不把这事一直呈报给他的老板。
He had to take two photos of an ass hat up to his boss who said either hat was fine, but wanted to know if it would be seen throughout the entire episode or just in this scene in Andy's office. We said it's just in this one scene. And so the message we received was that it's okay. Either hat provided it is just the one scene. No, I don't know why. If it's approved for one scene, why can't we just see it a lot? I guess just too much.
他得拿着两张屁股帽的照片去找他的老板，老板说哪顶帽子都行，但想知道它是会在整集里都出现，还是只在安迪办公室的这一个场景里出现。我们说它只在这一个场景里。所以我们收到的回复是没问题。不管哪顶帽子都可以，只要它只出现在这一个场景里。不，我不知道为什么。如果一个场景批准了，为什么我们就不能多看几次呢？我猜是因为太多了吧。
Because over time, we'll just only see asses. That's how I guess. I don't know, that's so silly. but they approved it for the scene. So I guess it all ended well. No pixelating. No pixelating. And we could have the word ass. We've talked about that for some reason that's an approved word. What I would have loved to have seen is them say like you can have the hat, but you must pixelate the crack. Well, we know they didn't wanna see any crack in the tattoo. Right. No crack.
因为随着时间的推移，我们眼里就只剩下屁股了。我想是这样的。我不知道，这太荒谬了。但他们批准在这个场景里使用。所以我想结局还不错。没有打码。没有打码。而且我们可以用“屁股”这个词。我们讨论过，出于某种原因，这是一个批准使用的词。我最想看到的是他们说，你可以用这顶帽子，但你必须给股沟打码。好吧，我们知道他们不想在纹身上看到任何股沟。没错。没有股沟。
There was a drawing of a tattoo and they said no crack. Well, there you have it, standards and practices. This is where Andy is gonna share with Dwight and Jim that there is someone who would like to be removed from their desk clump. They both immediately think it's each other and he's like, no, no, no, then they know. It's Kathy and they both whip to turn to look at her and he's like, don't look at her, but your incessant pranking and one-upsmanship is making her crazy and she would like to move.
有一个纹身的草图，他们说不要股沟。好吧，这就是标准与实践。接下来安迪要告诉德怀特和吉姆，有人希望能离开他们的座位群。他们俩立刻都以为对方是那个人，然后安迪说，不，不，不，接着他们就知道了。是凯西，他们俩同时猛地转头看她，安迪说，别看她，但你们没完没了的恶作剧和争强好胜把她逼疯了，她想换个座位。
They can't believe this and he goes, listen, respect the hat. Take me seriously or I'm gonna give one of you your Christmas bonuses and you have these sizable Christmas bonuses. That gets their attention. Mm-hmm. Now they know no more pranking. Well, Andy's gonna remove his hard ass hat now
他们简直不敢相信，安迪说，听着，尊重这顶帽子。认真对待我，否则我要把你们其中一个人的圣诞奖金扣下，你们俩的圣诞奖金可都挺丰厚的。这成功吸引了他们的注意。嗯。现在他们知道不能再恶作剧了。好吧，安迪现在要把他的严厉老板帽摘下来了
because he was only allowed to wear it in that one scene. But also because Jessica is arriving. Her first stop is Erin, who gives her a big hug. Yeah, and Andy's like, my ex is meeting my six. Mm-hmm. This scene is so awkward. I thought, I can't get more awkward than this. I was wrong. You were wrong because it's going to get more awkward. I thought, I can't get more awkward than this. I was wrong.
因为他只能在那一个场景里戴。但也是因为杰西卡来了。她的第一站是艾琳，艾琳给了她一个大大的拥抱。是的，安迪就像是，我的前任遇到了我的现任。嗯。这个场景太尴尬了。我想，不可能比这更尴尬了。我猜错了。你猜错了，因为接下来会更尴尬。我想，不可能比这更尴尬了。我猜错了。
You were wrong because it's gonna get more awkward. Well, Jessica was played by Eleanor Seagler, who appears in four episodes of The Office as Andy's girlfriend, Jessica. And she is just lovely. The character of Jessica is just normal and brings out this very normal, calm, grounded energy and Andy. Yeah. I really like Jessica for Andy. I'm rooting for them. Me too. Down in the warehouse, Darryl is chatting up Val and tries to casually invite her to the Christmas party.
你猜错了，因为接下来会更尴尬。好吧，杰西卡由埃莉诺·西格勒饰演，她在《办公室》里客串了四集安迪的女朋友杰西卡。她简直太可爱了。杰西卡这个角色非常正常，给安迪带来了一种非常正常、冷静、脚踏实地的能量。是的。我真的很喜欢安迪身边的杰西卡。我支持他们。我也是。在仓库里，达里尔正在跟瓦尔闲聊，并试图随口邀请她去参加圣诞派对。
I was cracking up because the whole time, Nate thinks he's invited as well. And he's just saying the most ridiculous things that he can't wait to dress up really nice for Darryl. I would have loved to see him more Nate upstairs at the party. Me too, because it sounds like this might be his first Christmas party. Ever.
我当时笑得不行，因为整个过程中，内特都觉得自己也被邀请了。而且他说的话荒唐极了，说什么他等不及要穿得漂漂亮亮去见达里尔了。我真希望能看到内特在楼上的派对上有更多戏份。我也是，因为听起来这可能是他的第一次圣诞派对。有生以来第一次。
Yes. We had a fan question from Elizabeth D in Virginia who said, I've been waiting to ask you this for years. My favorite line in the office is in this episode when Nate says, you had me at clookies. I can't wait to find out what they are. Elizabeth said, it's one of me and my brothers running bits and we quote it to each other in different ways.
是的。我们收到了来自弗吉尼亚州伊丽莎白·D的一位粉丝的提问，她说，我等了好几年想问你这个。我在《办公室》里最喜欢的一句台词就是这一集里内特说的，你一说“曲奇饼干”我就沦陷了。我等不及想知道它们到底是什么。伊丽莎白说，这是我和我兄弟们经常玩的一个梗，我们经常用各种方式引用它。
Please tell me how this joke came about. Well, that joke was scripted. They did it just as it was in the script, but my favorite part about this joke is actually the way Val looks at his Nate's arm after he says it's like when you reach over to like your husband and you want him to like stop talking at a dinner party or something,
请告诉我这个笑话是怎么来的。好吧，这个笑话是有剧本的。他们拍出来时就跟剧本里一模一样，但我最喜欢这个笑话的地方其实是瓦尔在内特说完话后看他手臂的那个眼神，就像你伸手去碰你的丈夫，想让他闭嘴，在晚宴上或者别的什么场合，
you're like, it's okay babe. It's okay. You can stop now. That was a great bit that Amina added to that. Yeah, it was a great button. We also got a fan question from Neil S in London UK who said, this scene opens with a Darryl teaching Val how to use the bailer and the training seems to consist
你会说，没事的宝贝。没事了。你现在可以停下来了。阿米娜加的那个小包袱太棒了。是的，那是个绝佳的包袱。我们还收到了来自英国伦敦尼尔·S的粉丝提问，他说，这个场景以达里尔教瓦尔如何使用打包机开场，而培训似乎包括
of telling her that it's capable of taking her armor head off so exercise caution. My question is, was this all the training that is required? This is the training that Michael didn't have in order to operate the dangerous machinery? Neil, I think yes. I think that Darryl really didn't want Michael to use the bailer. And so he invented this idea that there was some elaborate training to use the bailer, but really, it was just these couple of sentences.
告诉她这机器能把她的手臂连头一起扯掉，所以要小心操作。我的问题是，这就是全部所需的培训吗？这就是迈克尔为了操作危险机械而没有接受过的培训吗？尼尔，我想是的。我觉得达里尔其实根本不想让迈克尔使用打包机。所以他编造了这样一个说法，即使用打包机需要经过极其复杂的培训，但实际上，只有这几句话而已。
But that's what I want to believe. This Dwight and Jim Runner is about to kick off because Dwight really sets up his whole desk area in hopes that Jim will prank him. He has an open email. He has his car keys out. So many things to entice Jim. And Jim realizes really quickly, wow, Dwight really wants my bonus.
但这就是我愿意相信的。德怀特和吉姆的这条故事线要开始了，因为德怀特精心布置了他的整片办公区域，盼着吉姆来恶作剧。他开着电子邮件。他的车钥匙就放在外面。有太多东西在引诱吉姆了。吉姆很快就意识到，哇，德怀特真的很想要我的奖金。
And he's trying to entrap me. That means he can't drink at this party now because when he drinks, he gets real pranky. I thought that was a really funny line. Oh no, I thought John as Jim was so cute saying it. Andy calling out their pranking only escalated it because now they're going to try to prank each other to get the others bonus. It's true. He's kind of made it worse. Well, you know who is drinking? It's Aaron. Yes. She's going to go up to Robert, California at the bar.
他在设圈套陷害我。这意味着他今晚在派对上不能喝酒了，因为他一喝酒就会变得非常喜欢恶作剧。我觉得那句台词真的很好笑。噢不，我觉得约翰演的吉姆说这话时太可爱了。安迪指出他们的恶作剧反而起到了推波助澜的作用，因为现在他们要互相恶作剧来抢对方的奖金了。确实如此。他有点把事情搞砸了。好吧，你们知道谁在喝酒吗？是艾琳。是的。她要走向酒吧里的罗伯特·加利福尼亚。
And first, she's going to ask for a cola Kirkland brand and he says, don't you think maybe you want something stronger? You could get that soda from the kitchen. Yeah. I think you came here because you want a real drink. So he pours a bunch of shots for Phyllis, Ryan, Oscar, and Kevin and he pours one for Aaron and oh boy, Oscar and Kevin and he pours one for Aaron and oh boy. Jiminy Christmas. Jiminy Christmas indeed. Back in the Jim and Dwight pranking storyline, Jim thinks he's got Dwight. He's carefully reading his credit card number. Dwight's jotting it down well as it turns out Dwight buys Pam a $200 bouquet of flowers.
首先，她要了一瓶可乐，柯克兰品牌的，而罗伯特说，难道你不想来点更带劲的吗？你可以在茶水间拿到那种苏打水。是的。我想你来这里是因为你想喝一杯真正的酒。于是他给菲利斯、瑞安、奥斯卡和凯文倒了一大堆烈酒，他也给艾琳倒了一杯，噢天哪，奥斯卡和凯文，他还给艾琳倒了一杯，噢天哪。我的天哪。确实是我的天哪。回到吉姆和德怀特的恶作剧剧情中，吉姆以为自己把德怀特拿捏了。他正在仔细念出德怀特的信用卡号。德怀特认真地记了下来，结果证明德怀特给帕姆买了一束200美元的花。
Yes. $200. That's going to be a big ass bouquet of flowers. Yes. $200. That's going to be a big ass bouquet. Yeah. I think she deserves it. Because like I said, she's going to be doing a lot of out of office extra partners. I thought you would say that. That is now going to arrive to the party. She looks stunning.
是的。200美元。那得是一大束非常壮观的花。是的。200美元。那得是一大束花。是的。我觉得她应得的。因为就像我说的，她要做很多办公室以外的额外工作。我就知道你会这么说。她现在要抵达派对现场了。她看起来惊艳极了。
She is in a beautiful gown, like a floor length purple off shoulder gown. Yes, we talked with Amina about this. This is all because Darryl said people dress up for the Christmas party. And she took it quite literally. I have a catch in this scene and it's about how someone is dressed and it's not val. But it's in this scene. Look at what I wrote down. What is Kathy skirt?
她穿着一件漂亮的礼服，是一件拖地的紫色露肩礼服。是的，我们和阿米娜聊过这个。这全是因为达里尔说过大家会为圣诞派对盛装打扮。而她非常字面地理解了这句话。我在这个场景里发现了一个漏洞，是关于某个人的着装，不是瓦尔。但它确实在这个场景里。看看我记下了什么。凯西的裙子是什么鬼？
Oh, no, what is her skirt? It looks like something that like a kid made in like a sewing class. Okay, I know what you're talking about. Like a theater production. And it has this giant, crazy like elastic band. As you said it, I knew exactly what you meant immediately. It looks like when my sister took a sewing class. Yes, it's like the first skirt you learned to make. You learned to make. Yeah. There's no zipper on it because zippers are intermediate. So yeah.
哦，不，她的裙子是什么鬼？看起来就像小孩子在缝纫课上做的一样。好吧，我知道你在说什么。就像戏剧制作里的道具。而且它还有一条巨大、夸张的松紧带。你一说我就立刻明白你的意思了。看起来就像我姐姐上缝纫课时做的一样。是的，就像你学做的第一条裙子。你学做的裙子。是的。上面没有拉链，因为拉链对新手来说太难了。所以是的。
Yeah, it's a, it's a stinker. I'm going to say it. I'm sorry. Maybe when we get to interview Lindsay, we'll ask her about this skirt because Maybe when we get to interview Lindsay, we'll ask her about this skirt because, um, Wowser. In the conference room, Aaron is really holding court now. She is buzzed and doing impressions. Mm-hmm.
是的，这裙子太逊了。我要直说了。对不起。也许当我们采访林赛时，我们会问她关于这条裙子的问题，因为也许当我们采访林赛时，我们会问她关于这条裙子的问题，呃，天哪。在会议室里，艾琳现在真的是全场焦点了。她微醺了，还在模仿别人。嗯哼。
She's doing a pretty darn good impression of Stanley to his delight. Yeah, he's very tickled by it. But all of this is going to end when Dwight starts screaming. He's screaming that he's been attacked. And we find a porcupine in his drawer that he says clearly Jim has put there. Yes, Dwight is going to claim that his hand is lacerated, that he has been quilled, and he's going to tell Andy that Jim is to blame for this porcupine. But Jim is going gonna very clearly state.
她把斯坦利模仿得惟妙惟肖，斯坦利本人也非常高兴。是的，他被逗得很开心。但这一切将在德怀特开始尖叫时结束。他尖叫着说自己遭到袭击了。我们在他的抽屉里发现了一只豪猪，他说这绝对是吉姆放进去的。是的，德怀特声称他的手被划破了，他被豪猪刺扎了，他要告诉安迪，这只豪猪是吉姆的错。但吉姆非常明确地表态：
I'm sorry, but of this whole group of people, who do you think would have access to a porcupine? It's clearly Dwight. Yes, and Dwight ends up revealing that the porcupine's name is Henrietta. We got a lot of fan mail about this porcupine, just see from Sydney, Australia said, where did you guys get Henrietta from? How much does it cost mail about this porcupine. Jess C from Sydney, Australia said, where did you guys get Henrietta from?
对不起，但在这一群人里，你觉得谁能弄到一只豪猪？显而易见是德怀特。是的，最后德怀特透露这只豪猪的名字叫亨利埃塔。我们收到了很多关于这只豪猪的粉丝来信，来自澳大利亚悉尼的杰西·C说，你们是从哪弄来亨利埃塔的？关于这只豪猪，我们收到了很多粉丝来信。澳大利亚悉尼的杰西·C说，你们从哪弄来亨利埃塔的？
How much does it cost to rent a porcupine? And are there any special considerations or safety meetings for working with a porcupine? Well, Jess, as with most animals we used on the office, our porcupine came through Bob Dunn's animal services, the porcupine cost $1,500 for one day of work that included the cost of the animal and two trainers and the animal's transportation to and from the set. And Steve Burgess says, we always have safety meetings when we're working with animals.
租一只豪猪要花多少钱？跟豪猪合作有什么特别的注意事项或安全会议吗？好吧，杰西，就像我们在《办公室》里用过的大多数动物一样，我们的豪猪是通过鲍勃·邓恩动物服务公司找来的，这只豪猪一天的工钱是1500美元，其中包括动物本身的费用、两名驯兽师的费用，以及动物往返片场的交通费。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，我们跟动物合作时总是会开安全会议。
It didn't matter what animal, even if it was a dog, and the rules to keep animals and crews safe are really strict. And Steve Burgess told me that the trainers worked with rain before the scene to instruct him on how exactly to handle the porcupine without hurting himself or the animal. Now, I was not there, but Angela, you emailed me pictures of the porcupine.
不管是什么动物，哪怕只是一只狗，保证动物和剧组安全规则都是非常严格的。史蒂夫·伯吉斯告诉我，驯兽师在拍摄这个场景前跟雷恩合作过，指导他究竟该如何抱这只豪猪，才不会伤到他自己或动物。当时我不在现场，但安吉拉，你给我发了豪猪的照片。
I did, okay, so here's the thing. I have such a clear memory of this day. Next to rain, I'm the person standing closest to the porcupine. So I was very aware that I wanted to keep my movements very minimal. And I found in my digital email clutter an email I sent to Ed and rain. I took a picture of Rain holding the porcupine. And Ed is standing right behind him. It's a great picture.
是的，好吧，事情是这样的。我对这一天有着非常清晰的记忆。紧挨着雷恩，我就是离豪猪最近的人。所以我非常清楚地意识到，我想把自己的动作控制到最少。我在乱七八糟的电子邮箱里找到了一封我发给埃德和雷恩的邮件。我拍了一张雷恩抱着豪猪的照片。埃德就站在他身后。那是一张很棒的照片。
And Rain is wearing in the photo. These massive, long, thick leather gloves. They were specially given to him to hold her. And he was shown how to hold her. And her name in my email, I say, here's a photo of you guys with Penelope. Oh, Henrietta's real name is Penelope. Yes. These are the cutest names, by the way.
照片里的雷恩戴着一副巨大、厚实的皮手套。那是专门发给他用来抱豪猪的。而且还教了他怎么抱。在我的邮件里，我说，这是你们俩和佩内洛普的合影。哦，亨利埃塔的真名叫佩内洛普。是的。顺便说一句，这些名字太可爱了。
And also, the other memory I have of her is that she loved a snack. And they would give her stuff to snack on in that drawer. So she had a carrot. I think she had a corn on the cob, but she loved her snacks and they kept her very calm and happy. Well, you know, if you do get stung by a porcupine quill
另外，我对她的另一个记忆是她非常喜欢吃零食。他们会在那个抽屉里给她一些零食吃。所以她有一根胡萝卜。我想她还有一根玉米棒，但她非常喜欢零食，这让她非常冷静和开心。好吧，你知道的，如果你被豪猪刺扎了
because you know, there are people think that they shoot their quills at you, but they don't. It's more like a bee sting where they'll whip their tail and they'll like thwap you. Jenna, did you do some Googling, Jenna? No, I just know a lot about porcupines. You are full of it.
因为你知道，有些人以为它们会把刺向你发射出来，但它们不会。这更像是被蜜蜂蛰了一下，它们会猛地甩尾巴，然后“啪”地抽你一下。詹娜，你刚才是不是上网查过了，詹娜？没有，我对豪猪了解得很多。你少吹牛了。
Of course I did some Googling. Of course. So what happens if you get whapped with the porcupine tail and you get quilled? What do you do? A quill becomes more anchored in the skin the longer they're there. Ooh. They have these little barbs like it's very common actually for dogs to get quilled by a porcupine, because they'll kind of stick their nose down
我当然上网查过了。当然。那如果你被豪猪尾巴抽了一下并且被刺扎了，会发生什么？你该怎么办？刺在皮肤里停留的时间越长，扎得就越深。哦。它们有这种小倒刺，实际上狗被豪猪扎是很常见的，因为它们会把鼻子凑下去闻，
and then they'll get quilled. The body heat of whoever has been quilled, a human or a dog, it causes them to expand. Oh, no. And also burrow into your skin. And they can even migrate like all the way to your organs. Stop it. And you can die.
然后就会被刺扎到。无论是被扎到的人还是狗，其体温都会导致刺膨胀。噢不。甚至还会钻进你的皮肤里。它们甚至会一路游走到你的器官。住手。你会死的。
It's very dangerous. And so you need to go to a doctor or take your dog to a vet to be dequiled because you don't want to leave any of the barb in there at all. Sometimes they even have to do like a CT scan to make sure that no quill edges broke off. That is fascinating. Yeah, you don't want to get quilled and porcupines have up to 30,000 quills.
这非常危险。所以你需要去看医生，或者带你的狗去看兽医把刺拔出来，因为你绝对不想把任何倒刺留在里面。有时候他们甚至不得不做个CT扫描来确保没有任何刺尖断在里面。太迷人了。是的，你可不想被豪猪刺扎到，豪猪身上有多达3万根刺。
Wow. 30,000. Wow. I can tell you, Penelope, it was really chill and she had the sweetest little face and she just would hang out and nawn her carrot for the most part. They're very sweet animals. We should also mention storyline that's happening in the background of the scene is that Toby says that a lot of this reminds him of a plot of his latest Chad Flinderman novel, A Murder
哇。3万根。哇。我得说，佩内洛普真的很温顺，她有着一张最可爱的面孔，她大部分时间只是安静地呆着，啃着她的胡萝卜。它们是非常可爱的动物。我们还应该提一下这个场景背景中正在发生的故事，那就是托比说这让他想到了他最新的查德·弗林德曼小说《谋杀案》中的一个情节
for Framing. All of it. Toby was writing, cracks me up. I could have seen like a whole episode dedicated to his like one of his novels. Aaron has moved from impressions to dancing. What is this dancing? What is this backward scooch with their elbow going up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up up We got a fan question from Razel L in me and Ellie's hometown of St. Louis, Missouri. Who said, I've always loved Ellie's dance moves in this episode. Were there specific descriptions of the dance moves in the script or was this all Ellie? This was all Ellie.
构图。所有的这一切。托比在写作，这把我逗笑了。我真能想象出一整集专门献给他的其中一本小说。艾琳已经从模仿过渡到跳舞了。这是什么舞？这个往后倒着扭并把手肘向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上向上。我们收到了来自雷泽尔·L的粉丝提问，雷泽尔来自我和埃莉的家乡密苏里州圣路易斯。她说，我一直很喜欢埃莉在这集里的舞姿。剧本里对这些舞步有具体描述吗，还是这全靠埃莉自由发挥？这全靠埃莉自由发挥。
I looked in the script to see the scene description because you know, sometimes they did give us very specific action. But this is what it said. It said Dwight Ryan, Kelly, Kathy and Phyllis are in a dance circle. Erin is in the center. She is dancing up a storm. Her hair is down. Face is a little sweaty. But the dancing was guys, that was all Ellie. Ellie, you get some applause for those dance moves. For sure. That backwards elbow thing, I will never forget. And I kind of want to recreate it with you. I have to say, I really love the detail that Aaron's hair
我在剧本里找过场景描述，因为你知道，有时候他们确实会给我们非常具体的动作指示。但剧本是这么写的。上面写着：德怀特、瑞安、凯利、凯西和菲利斯围成了一个舞圈。艾琳在中间。她跳得正欢。头发披散着。脸有点出汗。但那舞姿，伙计们，那全靠埃莉自己发挥。埃莉，必须为这些舞姿给你鼓个掌。真的。那个往后倒的胳膊肘动作，我永远不会忘。而且我甚至有点想跟你一起重现一下。我必须得说，我真的很喜欢一个细节，那就是艾琳的头发
starts up, kind of looking nice. And then throughout the episode, it comes down and it gets frizzier and more frazzled. And she gets sweatier as she gets drunker. Angela, do you remember our friend that we have in common? And I won't say who it is because I won't embarrass her. But we were all at a party together and then like throughout the party she got drunker and her hair kept getting bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger. And I have pictures from the night. Yes, yes, I do. And you know what? If she's
刚开始时，看起来还挺整齐的。但整集演下来，头发散开了，变得越来越毛躁、越来越蓬乱。而且随着她越喝越多，人也开始冒汗。安吉拉，你还记得我们共同认识的那位朋友吗？我不会说是谁，因为我不想让她难堪。但我们当时一起去参加一个派对，然后随着派对的进行，她喝得越来越醉，她的头发就变得越来越大、越来越大、越来越大、越来越大。我有当晚的照片。是的，我的确有。你知道吗？如果她在
listening, she knows exactly who she is. She knows who she is. Oh my gosh, I love that. She's listening, she knows exactly who she is. She knows who she is. Oh my gosh, I love that. Oh my gosh. Well, I was actually in the scene with Jessica and Andy, you know, Angela's standing there with them when Aaron does this back scoots dance move and then says by the end of the night, she hopes to see them kiss and then she squeezes their heads together. I was standing right there.
听节目，她绝对知道自己是谁。她知道自己是谁。哦天哪，我太喜欢这个了。如果她在听，她绝对知道自己是谁。她知道自己是谁。哦天哪，我太喜欢这个了。哦天哪。好吧，我其实拍了杰西卡和安迪的那个场景，你知道的，当艾琳跳完这个后退的舞步，然后说希望在今晚结束前看到他们接吻，接着把他们的脑袋挤在一起时，安吉拉就站在他们旁边。我当时就站在那儿。
It was so awkward. Oh my gosh. And it was just as awkward to rewatch it. And when she leaves, that's when Jessica goes, that's who you dated. That's the girl you dated. And Andy's like, yeah, I mean, she's normally not like this, but I thought Eleanor delivered so many great moments in this episode, and that's one of them. Well, why don't we take a break because next up, Erin is going to tell Andy her Christmas wish, and it's seducey. It's so horrible. How do you come back from that?
太尴尬了。噢天哪。而且重看这一幕时同样尴尬。当她离开时，杰西卡就说了，这就是你约会过的人？这就是你约过会的女孩？然后安迪说，对啊，我是说，她平时不是这样的，但我认为埃莉诺在这集里贡献了非常多精彩的时刻，这就是其中之一。好吧，我们为什么不休息一下呢，因为接下来，艾琳要告诉安迪她的圣诞愿望，而且充满诱惑。太可怕了。这怎么收场啊？
I don't know. We're back and Andy goes in the conference room basically to check on Aaron. He's like, hey, I think you should eat something and she tells him her holiday wish and it's for Jessica to be dead, like in the ground with worms coming out of her. And Andy gets really angry and Says, you know what take it back. That's my girlfriend take it back and Aaron's like no you promised So what are you a liar or a murderer and everyone is witness to this moment to this argument And I'm thinking if you're Jessica standing right outside the partition there, that glass, you're watching this, you can probably hear it.
我不知道。我们回来了，安迪走进会议室基本上是为了查看艾琳的情况。他说，嘿，我觉得你应该吃点东西，然后艾琳就告诉了他她的节日愿望，那就是希望杰西卡去死，就像烂在土里、身上长满蛆虫那样。安迪非常生气，说道，你知道吗，把这话收回。那是我女朋友，把这话收回。而艾琳却说，不，你答应过我。所以你是撒谎精还是杀人犯？所有人都在现场目睹了这一幕，目睹了这场争吵。我在想，如果你是杰西卡，就站在隔断外面，隔着那块玻璃，你看着这一切，你很可能听得到。
How are you not like, you know what? F*** this, I'm out of here. Like she wants me dead. I'm not gonna stay and hang out at this party. I don't know, I kind of believe that maybe the music makes it hard to hear around the door and out in the place. That's what you have to believe, right? Yes, but I'm going to tell you what my favorite part
你怎么能不觉得，你知道吗？去他的，老娘不干了。这女的希望我死。我才不在这个派对上待着呢。我不知道，我宁愿相信也许音乐太大声了，让人很难听清门外和派对里的声音。你只能这么相信，对吧？是的，但我来告诉你我最喜欢的部分
of this scene was. It's the people dancing in the background. Because their dancing starts to kind of slowly disintegrate as the argument escalates. It is so fun. I watched it both with and without sound. I don't know. I was so tickled by it. Everyone's just like dancing their heart out and then slowly ever so slowly by the end they're just standing there staring and it's chef's kiss. Okay I'll look for it. Well now Phyllis is gonna tell Val that she thinks she looks like a princess and says,
是什么。是背景里跳舞的人。因为随着争吵升级，他们的舞姿开始慢慢变得散乱。太有趣了。我开着声音和关掉声音各看了一遍。我不知道。我被逗得不行。每个人都在用心跳舞，然后慢慢地，极其缓慢地，到了最后，他们只是站在那里盯着看，简直绝了。好吧，我去看看。现在菲利斯要对瓦尔说，她觉得瓦尔看起来像个公主，并说，
don't listen to what everyone else is saying. It's one of those backhanded compliments, right? Yes, yes. And this is the scene Amina was talking about in our interview because they gave Phyllis a whole bunch of alts like in the moment, right? These one-liners to go up to Val and say, and there are a bunch in the bloopers,
别听别人怎么说。这真是一句暗藏讽刺的恭维，对吧？是的，是的。这就是阿米娜在采访中提到的那个场景，因为他们在拍摄时给菲利斯加了一堆即兴台词，对吧？这些走到瓦尔面前说的俏皮话，花絮里还有一大堆呢，
but what is gonna happen is, Darryl is gonna clock this, right? He's gotta step up to the plate here for her. And he's gonna do the cutest thing, but we'll get to it. Yeah. Jim is now going to approach Andy, and Oscar, and Jessica, and Phyllis and he's going to show them a Vandalized photo of CC. He's trying to set Dwight up I went to the shooting draft because I was curious to see how it was described
但接下来会发生的是，达里尔注意到了这一点，对吧？他得为她挺身而出了。他要做一件超级可爱的事，不过我们一会儿就会聊到。好吧，吉姆现在要去找安迪、奥斯卡、杰西卡和菲利斯，他要给他们看一张被恶搞的西西的照片。他这是在给德怀特下套。我特意去翻了拍摄剧本，因为很好奇它是怎么描述的。
It says Jim shows them a photo of CC. It has been defaced with a sharpie. She has a handlebar mustache, a goatee, and devil's horns. Oscar is incensed. And let me tell you, if you go to the bloopers for this, there is one take where Oscar has a reaction that is so hilarious, everyone breaks. It reminded me, Jennifer, when he did unbeatable, but I want to put it in our stories because he does this thing, like it won't play here,
剧本上说，吉姆给他们看了一张西西的照片。照片上被用记号笔恶搞乱涂了一通。她留着八字胡、山羊胡，还顶着恶魔角。奥斯卡气炸了。跟你说吧，如果你去看这一集的NG花絮，有一个镜头里奥斯卡的反应太搞笑笑喷了，所有人全笑场了。这让我想起了，詹妮弗，他演无敌破坏王的时候，不过我想把它发到我们的快拍里，因为他做了个动作，这会儿没法演示，
but he goes like, ugh, like he does. Yes, this is huge reaction. And everyone's like, what was that? Well, Jim is going to do this really weird thing where, you know, Andy says, if Dwight did this, I'm going to fire him. Like this is bigger than just Christmas bonuses, to which now Jim has to back pedal and
但他会做出那种“呃”的表情，他就是会做这个。是的，这个反应太强烈了。大家都说，刚刚那是啥？好吧，吉姆要做一件非常奇怪的事情，安迪说，如果这是德怀特干的，我要开除他。这可比区区圣诞奖金严重多了，听到这儿吉姆不得不开始打退堂鼓，
Sort of maybe save maybe he did it. He can't remember it's coming back to him Maybe he was the one who did it. Everyone's so confused. Dwight is now gonna burst in the conference room in true Dwight fashion He is going to throw someone's iPod into the trash. He is done with that Christmas music He's gonna put his boom box on the table and knock over all the cups and everything. I mean, why could he just place it on the table? But no, he makes this big statement and hits play. And I loved this scene. This is so great. This is going to set off a big montage of gift giving and there's going to be a lot of rocking out in the conference room. Yeah, a lot of air guitar, very aggressive air guitar. We had a fan question for Maddie S in Russellville, Arkansas, who asked,
试图挽回，也许是他干的？他记不清了，记忆正在恢复，也许确实是他干的？大家都糊涂了。德怀特现在要以他特有的方式冲进会议室。他把某个人的iPod扔进了垃圾桶。他受够了那些圣诞音乐。他把自己的音箱拍在桌上，把所有的杯子什么的都撞翻了。我的意思是，他为什么就不能轻轻把音箱放在桌上呢？但没有，他发表了一番豪言壮语然后按下了播放键。我太喜欢这个场景了。太棒了。这即将拉开一大段送礼混剪的序幕，会议室里将会有一场疯狂的摇滚狂欢。是的，大量的空气吉他，非常具有攻击性的空气吉他。我们收到了来自阿肯色州拉塞尔维尔的马迪·S的粉丝提问，他问：
how much did it cost to play Transcyberian orchestra for this episode? I love TSO and loved white jamming out to this song. But the nerdy side of me has to wonder how much it costs to use one of their most popular well-known songs for this episode. Well Maddie, as you know, this song was Carol of the Bells by Transcyberian Orchestra, and it cost us $40,000 to use this song on the show. This song was scripted from the very beginning. It was the only song we wanted. Steve Burgess shared with me, though, that NBC had a deal with the office where the office
这一集里播放跨西伯利亚管弦乐团的音乐花了几多钱？我太喜欢TSO了，也特别喜欢德怀特跟着这首歌疯狂摇摆的样子。但作为一个极客，我很好奇在这集里使用他们最流行、最知名的歌曲之一到底要花多少钱。好吧，马迪，正如你所知，这首歌是跨西伯利亚管弦乐团的《铃儿响叮当》，我们在节目中使用这首歌花了4万美元。这首歌从一开始就是剧本里写好的。这是我们唯一的选择。不过史蒂夫·伯吉斯跟我分享说，NBC和办公室有一个协议，即办公室
only had to pay 12% of the song. So we technically got this for only $4,800. But here's a fun fact about TSO, which I thought was kind of cool. They were the first major rock band to go straight to performing in theaters and arenas. They never played it like any clubs. They were never anyone's opening act. They just were like a BATIO from the get go headliner. Very cool. All the way. Well, now we're going to have a montage of all the gifts. Oscar is gonna give Kevin a cookie jar.
只需支付这首歌12%的费用。所以从技术上讲，我们只花了4800美元就搞定了。但关于TSO有一个有趣的冷知识，我觉得挺酷的。他们是第一支直接去剧院和体育馆演出的主流摇滚乐队。他们从来没在什么小俱乐部演过。他们也从来不是任何人的开场暖场嘉宾。他们一出道就是大牌头牌乐队。太酷了。一路都是如此。好了，接下来我们要迎来一个礼物大混剪。奥斯卡要送给凯文一个饼干罐。
It's a woman dark cascading hairy sort of strapless gown. Yes, we had a fan question from Jessica in Rochester, New York, who says, who is that supposed to be? Well, I went to the script, Jessica. It was scripted as Sophia Fogara. I saw that too. That is who that is. So I don't know if we made that or what?
这是一个深色长发披肩、毛茸茸的无肩带礼服造型。是的，我们收到了来自纽约州罗切斯特的杰西卡的粉丝提问，她说，这到底捏的是谁啊？好吧，我去查了剧本，杰西卡。剧本里写的是索菲亚·福加拉。我也看到了。那就是她。所以我不知道是我们自己做的还是怎么回事？
I think it kind of looks like I've seen this cookie jar that is Marilyn Monroe. That's what it looked like to me too. And maybe they painted the hair. Yes. Yeah. Meredith is gonna give Jim a brochure for vasectomies. Ryan and Kelly give Angela a t-shirt that says, ask, then touch, she's so delighted by this.
我觉得它看起来有点像我见过的一个玛丽莲·梦露的饼干罐。我也觉得看起来像这个。也许他们把头发重新画了一下。是的。是的。梅雷迪思要送给吉姆一本输精管切除术的手术宣传册。瑞安和凯利送给安吉拉一件T恤，上面写着“先征求同意，再触碰”，她对此高兴极了。
Meanwhile, the air guitar is getting really heated. It is Nate Dwight and Creed, then Gabe joins in. When Creed joins in, it's so perfect. It's my favorite thing. So good. So much fun. I could have watched this montage for a longer period of time, I must say.
与此同时，空气吉他越来越白热化了。内特、德怀特和克里德都在弹，然后盖布也加入了进来。克里德加入的时候，简直太完美了。这是我最喜欢的部分。太棒了。太好玩了。我真希望能看这个混剪更长时间，我必须得说。
During this montage, there is a fantastic scene. It's in the deleted scenes where Meredith makes a play for Robert. It's so good. Oh, he's just kind of gazing at the Christmas tree, lost in thought. She saddles up next to him and says, I see you're a little down and he says, I am, I'm a mess. And Meredith says, how about I fix you some more milk with some bourbon?
在这个混剪期间，有一个非常棒的场景。它在删减片段里，梅雷迪思试图勾引罗伯特。太精彩了。哦，他当时正若有所思地盯着圣诞树发呆。她凑到他旁边说，我看出你有点闷闷不乐，罗伯特说，确实，我一团糟。梅雷迪思说，要不我给你倒点加了波本威士忌的牛奶？
And Robert says, oh, that sounds nice. And then Meredith says, maybe watch a movie under a blanket. Robert goes, lovely. Then he kind of comes to and he says, wait, where is this taking place? And Meredith says, the Murphy bed in my basement. And then Robert is not back to reality. He's like, what is happening to me? He rejects her advances and he says, I sincerely hope you find a sexual partner tonight
罗伯特说，哦，听起来不错。然后梅雷迪思说，也许我们可以裹着毯子看个电影。罗伯特说，听着挺美。然后他回过神来说，等等，这要在哪进行？梅雷迪思说，我地下室的墨菲床。然后罗伯特瞬间回到了现实。他说，我这是怎么了？他拒绝了她的求爱，并说道：我衷心希望你今晚能找到一个性伴侣。
And you know what Robert California only says what he really means. So he really does and Seerly, yeah hope it's not gonna be him, but he wishes her well There's a scene in the anox that is one of my faves Mindy Kaling just crushes it Ryan and Kelly are on Kelly's computer. She has a lot of viruses. You don't really know what the scene is about. Aaron walks in and says, game on.
你知道罗伯特·加利福尼亚只会说他真心实意的话。所以他是真的，衷心地，是的，希望那个人不是他，但他祝她一切顺利。办公室阁楼里有一场戏是我的最爱。敏迪·卡灵简直绝了。瑞安和凯利在凯利的电脑前。她的电脑中了很多病毒。你其实不太清楚这个场景在讲什么。艾琳走进来，说，游戏开始。
And oh my gosh, Mindy's shift as Kelly where she's just like on it. Yeah. And what that means is that Kelly is gonna take down Jessica. So we've got Phyllis Angelen Oscar. She did the thing where you walk up laughing. That's what I was gonna say.
噢天哪，敏迪饰演凯利时的那种状态转换，简直是说到做到。是的。这意味着凯利要对付杰西卡了。所以我们有菲利斯、安吉拉和奥斯卡。她做那个走过来大笑的动作。这就是我要说的。
And you know what? It was scripted. It says that Kelly approaches, joins in on the laughter, and then says her line, Jessica, did you fart? It is like the record scratch. Everyone's like, uh, Jenna, we could not get through this. And I thought there'd be some on the bloopers. I know they're out there somewhere. We kept getting so tickled. But anyway, she's like, Jessica, did you fart? And then it cuts immediately to a Kelly talking head. And she goes, and that is how
你知道吗？这是剧本写好的。上面说凯利走过来，加入到笑声中，然后说出了她的台词：杰西卡，你放屁了吗？现场就像唱片卡壳了一样。所有人都惊呆了，呃，詹娜，我们简直无法顺利拍完这段。我知道花絮里肯定有这段。我们当时笑得停不下来。总之，她说，杰西卡，你放屁了吗？然后镜头立刻切到一个凯利面对镜头的单采，她说，这就是
it's done. And I loved that talking head. There was an alt-kelly talking head here where she has a little bit more to say about her strategy of taking someone down and it goes like this. You don't want to get too clever with a takedown. When I was younger, I would overthink a mean comment, get precious with it.
搞定的方式。我太喜欢那个单采了。这里其实还有一个备用的凯利单采，里面她对搞定某人的策略说了更多细节，内容是这样的：你对付别人的时候可不能太耍小聪明。我年轻的时候，会把一个刻薄的评论琢磨过头，把它搞得矫揉造作。
But over time, I've learned you just want your insult to be simple, direct, relatable, and then you wanna move on. She's not wrong. That's her full philosophy. Well, you know, there's been a few times you and I have talked about where we're like, huh, Jim hasn't brought up Pam.
但随着时间推移，我学到了，你其实只想让你的侮辱变得简单、直接、接地气，然后你就赶紧翻篇。她没说错。这就是她的完整哲学。好吧，你知道的，有好几次你和我讨论过，我们都会觉得，咦，吉姆怎么一直没提帕姆？
We haven't heard anything about Pam and the kids. Where's Pam and the kids? There was a scene, it's in deleted scenes, where Jim receives a package. Aaron very loudly and drunkly says, Hey, you got a package. Do you want me to put it on your desk? And he says, Sure, Aaron throws it across the room and hits Kathy with it. And then it cuts to Jim opening the package and the package is from Pam. There's a card that says season greetings on the outside and when you open it on the inside, Pam wrote, Cece heard there was a tree at work, love Pam. And it is a very cute homemade ornament.
我们怎么没听到任何关于帕姆和孩子们的消息？帕姆和孩子们去哪儿了？有一个场景在删减片段里，吉姆收到了一个包裹。艾琳非常大声而且醉醺醺地说，嘿，你有个包裹！要我帮你放在桌上吗？吉姆说，好啊，艾琳直接把包裹隔空扔了过去，结果砸中了凯西。接着镜头切到吉姆打开包裹，包裹是帕姆寄来的。外面有一张卡片写着“节日快乐”，当你打开里面时，帕姆写道：西西听说公司里有一棵树，爱你的帕姆。这是一个非常可爱的自制装饰品。
This is how the ornament was described. A homemade ornament made out of colored construction paper. It's a star with dried macaroni and beans and glitter on it. Jim smiles and hangs it on the tree. Well, that would have gone to their tradition of exchanging homemade holiday gifts at the Dundermiffland party. I know. I know. I thought I missed the scene. We talk about sometimes in deleted scenes. Oh, maybe it should have been in. Maybe it shouldn't. I liked it. Erin approaches the bar for more alcohol.
这个装饰品是这样描述的：一个用彩色手工纸做成的自制装饰品。那是一颗星星，上面贴满了干通心粉、豆子和亮片。吉姆微笑着把它挂在了树上。好吧，这符合他们在邓德米夫林派对上互送自制节日礼物的传统。我知道。我知道。我以为我漏掉了这个场景。我们有时会讨论删减片段。哦，也许它应该保留在正片里。也许不该。我挺喜欢它的。艾琳走向酒吧想要更多酒精。
But Robert thinks maybe she needs to take a walk. He suggests Oscar take over his bartender, but oh my gosh, I mean, he hasn't tended bar in year. He's going to need, he needs a mortar and pestle, a mudlerler some chocolate shaving You know As a mixologist. Oh, I love this moment. I looked in the shooting draft and it said Oscar looks around excitedly to no one and
但罗伯特觉得也许她需要去散散步。他建议奥斯卡接替他当酒保，但是噢天哪，我的意思是，他已经好几年没调过酒了。他需要，他需要一个研钵和研杵、一个捣碎棒、一些巧克力碎屑……你知道的，作为一个调酒师。噢，我太喜欢这个时刻了。我在拍摄剧本里查到，上面写着奥斯卡兴奋地环顾四周，却发现没人理他，
He would have had a talking head where he shared that for a little bit of time He bartended in the East Village in 1983. Oh My gosh. Oh, that's fun back story. Well, Robert and Aaron go outside and they're sort of commiserating over their mutual broken hearts. And Andy is watching this from the conference room window. He's going to start to get a little jealous. Yeah. a little worried that maybe something's happening. And once again, Mark, who plays Nate, just has the most subtle but awesome comedy bomb that he drops. He just looks at Jessica and asks her how she does her makeup. How long does it take her? These moments with him crack me up so much. And that was not scripted. Oh, no way.
他本来应该有一个单采，在里面分享说他在1983年的东村当过一会儿调酒师。噢天哪。噢，这背景故事真有趣。好吧，罗伯特和艾琳走到外面，他们俩有点在互相倾诉彼此破碎的心。安迪从会议室的窗户里看着这一幕。他开始有点吃醋了。是的，开始有点担心是不是发生了什么。而又一次地，饰演内特的马克，抛出了他那最微妙却又绝佳的喜剧包袱。他只是看着杰西卡，问她平时是怎么化妆的。这要花她多长时间？这些由他制造的时刻把我逗得前仰后合。而且那根本不是剧本里写的。噢，绝不可能。
That was just, Nate, yeah, because in the script, the only note is that Andy is looking out the window. So Mark improvised that? Yes, they had to just improvise some chit chat. That is amazing. And Eleanor's response as Jessica was perfect. I know. Well, in the bullpen, Toby is really boring, Val,
那完全是——内特，是的，因为在剧本里，唯一的提示就是安迪在往窗外看。所以马克是即兴发挥的？是的，他们必须即兴扯几句闲话。太惊人了。而埃莉诺作为杰西卡的反应简直完美。我知道。好吧，在大办公区里，托比一直在跟瓦尔唠叨，
by talking about Chad Flindermann. I was curious if there was more to this moment right before Darryl walks in. So I went to the script and it says, Toby is by Val who looks really bored. Toby says, Chad Flindermann's kryptonite, if you will, is avocado, which is bad news if you're a private dick in Southern California. Oh, boy. But all that made it in was Flindermann's kryptonite, but that's actually the full dialogue. His kryptonite is avocado.
跟他聊着查德·弗林德曼。我很想知道达里尔走进来之前的那一刻还有没有更多内容。所以我去翻了剧本，上面写着：托比坐在看起来一脸无聊的瓦尔旁边。托比说，如果非要说的话，查德·弗林德曼的克星是牛油果，如果你是南加州的一个私家侦探，这可不是什么好消息。哦，天哪。但最终播出的只有“弗林德曼的克星”，但这其实才是完整的台词。他的克星是牛油果。
Yes, very tough if you live in Southern California and you're a private detective. I'll tell you what's hard living in Southern California is if you have a cilantro allergy. Oh, it's in every thing because California cuisine, they love a cilantro. And I'm one of those people where it tastes like soap. It tastes like you just squeeze dish soap all over my food. And I bit constantly confused like, why does everyone in California like this flavor turns out, you know, not everyone tastes it that way. But yeah, it tastes like raw fish to me. Is that what cilantro tastes like? this flavor turns out, you know, not everyone tastes it that way, but yeah.
是的，如果你住在南加州又是个私家侦探，那可真是太难了。我告诉你住在南加州什么地方最难，那就是如果你对香菜过敏。哦，那东西无处不在，因为加州菜里，他们超级爱放香菜。而我就是那种觉得它尝起来像肥皂的人。尝起来就像有人把洗洁精直接挤到了我的食物上。我常常感到困惑，为什么加州所有人都喜欢这种味道呢？后来我才知道，原来不是所有人尝起来都是这个味道的。但确实，对我来说它尝起来像生鱼。香菜是这个味道吗？这种味道，你懂的。
The taste like raw fish to me. Is that what cilantro tastes like? To me, it does. And I don't, I don't care for it. It's not a type of raw fish I'm enjoying. Lady, maybe you have the allergy. Maybe I do. And I just know I just don't like the taste of it.
对我来说就是。而且我，我可不吃它。这不是那种我会喜欢的生鱼的味道。美女，也许你对它过敏。也许吧。我只知道我就是不喜欢那个味道。
I think it tastes like dish soap, but there you go. Anyway, well, Darryl is made a very dashing gesture here. He is now arrived in a full texito. This is a very Jim move. Jim would do this, right? OG Jim? That's right, Romance. Well, Val is pleased.
我觉得它尝起来像洗洁精，不过就是这样。不管怎样，达里尔在这里做了一个非常潇洒的举动。他现在穿着一身燕尾服登场了。这太有吉姆的风格了。吉姆会这么做，对吧？老派吉姆？没错，浪漫。好吧，瓦尔很高兴。
She's like, she's feeling it. The party is wrapping up. Let's all remember, it's been going on since 11 a.m It is done Meredith is on the floor Jessica's like I'm gonna go home and he's got a pile Meredith into the van and Robert is giving Aaron a ride home Well when Andy goes to put his bike in the back of the van a ton of stuff falls out now
她觉得，她有感觉了。派对要结束了。大家记住，这个派对从早上11点就开始了。终于结束了。梅雷迪思倒在地上，杰西卡说我要回家了，然后他得把梅雷迪思塞进面包车里，而罗伯特正开车送艾琳回家。好吧，当安迪把他的自行车放进面包车后备箱时，一大堆东西哗啦掉出来了。现在
I just want to remind you, this is the same van that was struck by lightning the week before us and had caught on fire. All this stuff in it. They managed to repair it quickly enough that it was usable for this episode. Here is how the back of the van was described in the script. Andy pushes his bike in, knocking out a sack of topsoil, a baby bassinet filled with dirty, beanie babies, the top rack of a dishwasher, a big tank of helium, and a picket sign that says Justice for Kayleigh. These are the things that were scripted to be in the back of Meredith's fan,
我只想提醒大家，这就是前一个星期被雷击中并着过火的那辆面包车。车里塞满了各种东西。他们设法以最快速度修好了它，以便能在这一集里使用。剧本里是这样描述面包车后备箱的：安迪把他的自行车推进去，撞出了一袋营养土、一个装满了脏兮兮的豆豆娃玩偶的婴儿提篮、一个洗碗机的顶层碗架、一大罐氦气瓶，还有一个写着“还凯利公道”的抗议标语牌。这些就是剧本里写好的放在梅雷迪思面包车后备箱里的东西，
that she is saying are her treasures. Her treasures! Kate Flannery is so off the charts amazing in these scenes. I just loved her when she was like, my stuff! She's like so pissed off. It's true. We had a fan question from D'Arapie and Grand Haven Michigan who wanted to know if Meredith's tantrum was scripted because she thought it was just perfect. I will say it was a combination of scripted and improvised. Yep.
她还管这些叫她的宝藏。她的宝藏！凯特·弗兰纳里在这些场景里的表现简直好得突破天际了。我太喜欢她喊“我的东西！”时的样子了。她气急败坏的。确实如此。我们收到了来自密歇根州大黑文的达拉·皮的粉丝提问，她想知道梅雷迪思的脾气爆发是不是剧本写好的，因为她觉得这一段完美极了。我必须说，这是剧本规定和即兴发挥的结合。没错。
We should say the Jim and Dwight storyline is wrapping up with the fact that Andy tells Jim he's calling off the whole prank thing and one of them getting each other's Christmas bonus. And Andy's like, I'll tell Dwight. And Jim's like, no, no, no, I'll tell him. I'll tell him. And of course, he never does.
我们应该提一下，吉姆和德怀特的剧情线收尾了，因为安迪告诉吉姆他要取消整个恶作剧活动，不搞什么谁拿谁圣诞奖金的事了。安迪说，我去告诉德怀特。而吉姆说，不不不，我去告诉他。我去告诉他。当然，他根本没去。
So Dwight continues to try to set up Jim by pranking himself. He's written idiot on his forehead. And now he's spray painting Jim is awesome onto his own car. That's right. And Jim has his drunk pranky moment where he's like, oh yeah, I was supposed to tell Dwight something.
所以德怀特继续通过整蛊自己来试图给吉姆下套。他在自己的额头上写了“笨蛋”。现在他正在自己的车上喷漆“吉姆太棒了”。没错。而吉姆则有了他那种喝醉后的恶作剧时刻，他说，哦对哦，我本该告诉德怀特一件事的。
After the scene, there was one more Dwight trying to set up Jim prank. It's in deleted scenes. Dwight explains that he got this bucket and he put all kinds of disgusting stuff in the bucket, expired food, raw eggs, just gross stuff. He balances the bucket on the door coming out of the kitchen into the bullpen, waiting for Jim to walk under it and get doused. But instead of Jim, it's Kathy! Kathy walks under it! And we filmed it! And this bucket of goo falls onto Lindsay. And it got cut! Can you imagine she did this gross
在这场戏之后，还有一个德怀特试图陷害吉姆的恶作剧。在删减片段里。德怀特解释说他找来一个水桶，在水桶里放了各种各样的恶心东西，过期的食物、生鸡蛋，全都是恶心的玩意儿。他把水桶平衡在从茶水间通往大办公区的门框上，等着吉姆从下面走过去被泼一身。但走过去的不是吉姆，是凯西！凯西从下面走了过去！我们把这拍下来了！这个装满黏糊糊东西的水桶扣到了林赛头上。结果被剪掉了！你能想象她经历了这么一个恶心的
bucket stunt? And then it got cut from the episode. She could commiserate with Kate because Kate would do a lot of that kind of crazy physical comedy stuff and then it wouldn't get in the episode. Yeah, in this episode, Cathy got hit with a package and she got a bucket of goo dumped on her. But Jenna, now that I'm thinking of it,
水桶特技吗？结果它在正片里被剪掉了。她可以跟凯特同病相怜了，因为凯特以前也会拍很多这种疯狂的肢体喜剧，然后却进不了正片。是的，这一集里，凯西先是被包裹砸中，接着又被一桶黏糊糊的东西当头浇下。但是詹娜，现在我想想，
maybe that explains the skirt. Oh. maybe that character doesn't get really nice wardrobe if they're going to get a bucket of goo dumped on them. Maybe you're right. This episode ends with Andy following Robert and Aaron home. Yeah. And kind of spying on them and Meredith is like, oh, aha. And he's like, shut your drunk hole, Meredith. Mm-hmm. But as it turns out, Robert is truly just giving Erin a ride home. He's actually kind of taking a bit of a fatherly approach with her in the same way that Michael did.
也许这就解释了那条裙子。哦。也许那个角色如果没有安排一桶黏糊糊的东西当头浇下的话，就穿不到什么特别好看的服装吧。也许你是对的。这一集以安迪尾随罗伯特和艾琳回家作为结尾。是的，还偷偷监视他们，梅雷迪思说，哦，啊哈。然后安迪说，闭上你那喝醉的嘴，梅雷迪思。嗯哼。但事实证明，罗伯特真的只是顺便送艾琳回家。他实际上对她采取了一种有点像父亲般的态度，就像迈克尔以前做的那样。
Yeah, he's like, take some aspirin, drink a lot of water. You're gonna be okay. Yeah. But I think what's really revealed here is that maybe Andy still has a little interest there. Yeah. And that's going to come out in a future episode. Oh, yeah. Well, guys, there you go. That's Christmas wishes.
是的，他就像是，吃点阿司匹林，多喝点水。你会没事的。是的。但我觉得这里真正揭示的是，也许安迪对她还是有点余情未了。是的。这会在以后的剧集里表现出来。噢，是的。好了，伙计们，这就是全部内容了。这就是圣诞愿望。
Christmas wishes. What's your Christmas wish this year, Jenna? To have a functional shoulder. Oh, lady. You will. You will. You're doing all the things. It's going to heal. functional shoulder. Oh lady. You will. You will. You're doing all the things that's gonna heal. It is. I know.
圣诞愿望。詹娜，你今年的圣诞愿望是什么？想要一个健康的肩膀。哦，天哪。你会的。你一定会的。你正在做所有的康复努力。它会痊愈的。健康的肩膀。哦天哪。你会的。你一定会的。你正在做所有的康复努力，它会痊愈的。一定会的。我知道。
I would just love to put my hair in a ponytail right on top of my head again. Oh. That's when I know I'm at 100%. But listen, a big thank you to Steve Burgess for all his insider info and just a ginormous thank you and hug and gratitude to Amina Kaplan for joining us for an interview on this one.
我真的好想再次把头发扎成马尾辫，就扎在头顶那种。哦。那就说明我恢复百分之百了。不过听着，非常感谢史蒂夫·伯吉斯分享的所有内幕信息，还要向阿米娜·卡帕尔加入我们的采访致以巨幅的感谢、拥抱和感激。
Absolutely, Amina, you made our day and we hope you guys all have a great day and a great rest of the week and we'll see you next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwulf, Jennifer Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Keifer. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbleco. Our theme song is rubber tree by Creed Bratton. For add-free versions of Office Ladies, go to Stitur premium.com.
绝对的，阿米娜，你让我们这一天过得很开心，我们希望你们大家都能度过美好的一天以及愉快的一周，我们下周见。回见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍妮弗·费雪和安吉拉·金西联合制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的驻场录音师是萨姆·基弗。我们的剪辑与混音师是乔丹·达菲，我们的副制作人是艾斯利·巴布科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉特森演唱的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请前往Stitcher Premium点com。
For a free one month trial of Stitur premium use code Office. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
使用优惠码“Office”即可免费试用Stitcher Premium一个月。你还没有对这一集发表评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。